Die Freiheit ist indivisibel. Und wenn ein Mann entgegengeblieben ist, sind alle nicht frei. And therefore, as a free man, I take pride in the words, ich bin ein Berliner.
Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße euch zur 190. Ausgabe. Und im neuen Jahr ist es dann auch gleich die erste. Also die erste, die ich zumindest in diesem Jahr aufnehme. Und ein Blick in die Aufzeichnungen, in die alten Schriften der Alten zeigt mir, dass ich schon viel zu lange keinen Podcast mehr mit Maha gemacht habe. Deswegen hole ich das jetzt nach. Hallo Maha.
Ja, hallo Tim.
Ist schon eine Weile her.
Ja, 2008 glaube ich. So was, ewig.
Da hatten wir mal einen guten Lauf und haben gleich drei nicht direkt in Folge gemacht, aber zumindest alles recht nah beieinander.
Richtig, ja.
Also ganz folgenlos war das ja nicht, ne?
Ne, da hat sich ja nichts getan. Wir haben ja damals den ersten Beitrag zum Thema Neusprech gemacht.
Genau, also ursprünglich haben wir uns mal über Sprachen unterhalten. Das fand ich schon mal sehr interessant. Und dann, abgesehen von der Episode, die sich der Wikipedia gewidmet hat, im Neusprech.
Ja, genau.
Das ist ja mittlerweile ein richtiges Steckenpferd geworden.
Genau, ja, das hat sich dann sehr entwickelt. Also ich bin ja damals dazu gekommen, weil ich einen Vortrag halten sollte über Neusprech in Dresden. Die Dresdener hatten sich das ja gewünscht. Und das war ja gar nicht so mein Thema. Und dann habe ich das irgendwie erzählt. Und du meintest, dann machen wir noch mal einen Podcast drüber.
Genau, meinte ich.
Genau. Und das war dann der erste Beitrag zum Thema. Da war ich noch völlig neu in dem Bereich.
Ganz neu im Neusprech. Ja, aber mittlerweile hast du dich da ja richtig gemütlich gemacht. Und zusammen mit dem Kai Biermann.
Richtig, mit dem mache ich ja einen Blog.
Genau, das dann passenderweise auch neusprech.org heißt.
Ja, das passt ja dann. Es geht ja um Neusprech.
Genau, und dann auch gleich mal ein Grimme-Online-Award abgeholt hat.
Im letzten Jahr, 2011, gab es dann ein Grimme-Online-Award dafür. Dann sieht man, was sich alles so entwickeln kann.
War das, kam das überraschend?
Das kam sehr überraschend. Also ich habe nicht damit gerechnet. Also ich war ja schon mal beteiligt an einem Grimme-Award, damals für die Wikipedia. Den sollte ich ja auch mit in den Empfang nehmen. Und da war das vorher schon angedeutet worden, uns gegenüber. Und deshalb hatte ich gedacht, naja, diesmal wird auch wieder was angedeutet, wenn man nominiert ist und tatsächlich eine Chance hat. Und es wurde nichts angedeutet. Und da habe ich gedacht, naja, das wird sowieso nix. Vor allen Dingen, ich habe die Mitbewerber gesehen, habe gedacht, das sind alle so tolle Projekte. Da wird man nicht das nehmen, weil wir ja auch eigentlich gerade erst angefangen hatten. Ja, aber dann kam es, wie es gab. Und dann waren wir plötzlich Grimme-Preisträger.
Ja, aber es zeigt auf jeden Fall, dass das Thema einen interessanten Nerv getroffen hat. Das ist irgendwie, dass die Auseinandersetzung mit Sprache und die Auseinandersetzung auch eben mit diesem Polit-Sprech wohl überfällig gewesen ist. Und dass dieser Blick da drauf dann auf hochbaren Boden gefallen ist.
Ja, das ist richtig. Da haben wir wirklich einen Nerv getroffen. Das sieht man ja auch an den Zugriffszahlen. Und wir sehen natürlich auch, es gab ja dann auch nach dem Grimme Award, also erst danach, also man braucht wahrscheinlich so einen Preis, gab es auch verstärktes Interesse von Verlagen, da ein Buch rauszumachen und es wird jetzt auch ein Buch entstehen und in diesem Jahr, im Dezember, auf dem Markt sein. Ja, das kriegen wir schon hin, denke ich. Wir haben ja schon vorgearbeitet.
Na gut, also um Sprache soll es auch heute gehen, allerdings nicht um den Neusprech. Das ist jetzt an anderer Stelle ausreichend gut behandelt. Aber es ist so ein anderes Thema, was ich eigentlich schon längere Zeit mal hier auf den Sockel heben wollte, weil mich das auch selber beschäftigt, ohne dass ich mich groß jemals damit beschäftigt hätte. Rhetorik, weiß nicht, beschreibe ich das korrekt, wenn ich sage so die Kunst des Redens? Okay, und dass es gute Redner und schlechte Redner gibt, das ist ja offensichtlich. Was eine gute Rede ausmacht, das wollen wir hier mal besprechen. Rein subjektiv, also man spürt das ja irgendwie, wenn jemand gut redet. Man merkt das, weil es einen irgendwie packt und weil es irgendwie einen mitnimmt, oder weil es einfach nicht langweilig wird. Bei jeder Veranstaltung kann man das immer wieder aufs Neue erleben. Nicht selten sterben Veranstaltungen schon in den ersten fünf Sekunden, wenn so der Keynote-Speaker oder noch schlimmer irgendwie so derjenige, der das Geld gegeben hat, so die ersten Grußworte richtet und dann einfach innerhalb kürzester Zeit die komplette, bis dahin vielleicht noch durchaus wohlwollende Masse so in so einem Tiefschlaf taucht, auf dem es sich dann so schnell nicht wieder erholt.
Ja, Grußworte sind immer ganz furchtbar. Also meistens nichts gesagt, das ist immer so formelhaft. Und dann gibt es natürlich Leute, die reden zu viel über nichts.
Naja, also das wollen wir jetzt mal so ein bisschen ergründen, was eigentlich diese Spannung letzten Endes ausmacht und was so eine erfolgreiche Redekunst ausmacht. Das ist ja eigentlich auch ein wichtiges Rüstzeug.
Genau.
Also jetzt auch unabhängig davon. Also Reden halten, gut ist das eine, aber es geht ja auch so im unmittelbaren Dialog mit anderen, es geht ja auch um das, wie soll ich sagen, dem eigenen Wunsch einen Ausdruck verleiht. Gerade wenn man debattiert und nicht unbedingt nur vorträgt, also auch ein bestimmtes Ziel verfolgt, versucht, was weiß ich, seine Meinung oder zumindest sein Anliegen zu unterstreichen, da kann das ja auch alles hilfreich sein.
Genau, also natürlich kann man das immer gebrauchen, also man muss immer irgendwann reden, also nicht nur unbedingt eine Rede schwingen, gut das braucht man auch, es gibt ja diese Gelegenheitsreden, dass man irgendwie mal was sagen muss, beim Geburtstag der Eltern oder so, aber natürlich auch in der Debatte, das ist ganz richtig und deshalb üben das ja auch viele in sogenannten Debattierclubs, das ist ja auch so eine Welle, die es jetzt auch wieder nach Europa geschafft hat, dass halt Leute zusammen debattieren.
Was heißt das, so Vereine oder?
Na, das muss nicht ein Frage geben, man trifft sich und dann wird halt debattiert, dann gibt es ein Thema und verschiedene Parteien, die halt gegeneinander antreten und die eine oder die andere Position vertreten.
Ach, und das ist ein Trend grad?
Aber du hast was verpasst.
Hast du schon mal an einem teilgenommen?
Nein, habe ich leider noch nicht, aber ich kenne Leute, die das machen. Zum Beispiel Zeitweise in München.
Ja, der war auch hier schon zu Gast bei dem Thema Brettspiele. Ach wirklich?
Der debattiert im Debattierclub. In Hamburg gibt es das auch. Also zum Beispiel an der Bucerius Law School, da gibt es eine Mood-Haul. In der Mood-Haul wird regelmäßig debattiert.
In der Mood-Haul?
Nicht Mood, sondern MUT. M-O-O-T.
M-O-O-T? Ach, warum heißt die denn so?
Da müssen wir in der Wikipedia nachgucken, das weiß ich nicht.
Aber jetzt nicht wegen dieses Viert-Schan, Vort-Schan.
Also jedenfalls da wird debattiert. Das ist auch schon so aufgebaut vorne, dass es da so zwei Redner-Pulte gibt, damit die Kontrahenten direkt da auch stehen können und so. Ja, das ist ein Trend, ja. Da hast du vielleicht was, was freut mich, dass ich mal was merke, was Tim noch nicht auf dem Radar hat.
Ach, ich hab so einiges nicht auf dem Radar. Wie schon gesagt, ich bin da affin, ich rede ja gerne. Merkt man ja auch, deswegen mach ich das ja hier auch. Aber ich hab mir ehrlich gesagt selten wirklich jetzt so strukturell Gedanken darüber gemacht, wie ich rede. Also eigentlich, meine Rede ist intuitiv. Von daher hab ich auch keine Ahnung, was so mein Verbesserungspotenzial ist. Schauen, wie ich hier aus der Sendung rausgehe.
Ja, natürlich kann man da vieles auch intuitiv, das ist ja klar.
Gut, aber ich meine, Sprache ist ja mal wieder altes Gut. Was heißt denn Rhetorik eigentlich genau? Also warum dieses Wort?
Das ist ein griechisches Wort für Rhetna. Rhetor ist der Redner und Rhetorik ist dann eine Ableitung davon. Also Technik, die Kunst, das aber auch, und dann das Adjektiv dazu, Rhetorik. Oder auf griechisch, auf lateinisch dann Ars, Rhetorika. Also die Kunst, die rednerische Kunst, wenn man es ganz wörtlich übernimmt. Rhetor, der Redner, die rednerische Kunst.
Die rednerische Kunst. Ja, und wer hat das Programm startet? Ich meine, in den Griechen wurde ja schon viel geredet.
Ja, genau, deshalb war das in der Antike auch ganz wichtig. Also die Leute haben sehr schnell erkannt, dass man im Vorteil ist, wenn man gut reden kann. Man traf sich ja in Berlin, um alle möglichen Dinge zu tun, also Gerichtsverhandlungen abzuhalten oder auch irgendwie den Staat zu leiten auf dem Marktplatz, also in Athen insbesondere, aber auch in den anderen Städten. Da gibt es also diese Agora, also ein großer Platz. In Athen ist der unterhalb der Akropolis. Das ist auch noch so praktisch, er ist dann auch so am Hang, dass man da auch gleich gut stehen kann. Und jeder hören kann, wer da gerade spricht. Ja, und da musste dann eben reden gehalten werden. Und dann hat man halt sehr schnell herausgefunden, dass ein guter Redner im Vorteil ist. Und dann haben sich Leute natürlich damit beschäftigt. Warum hat der jetzt alle überzeugt? Was macht der? Dann hat man es auseinandergenommen. Und so war dann die Rhetorik erfunden. Die Rhetorik, die dann einerseits auch als Schulung dient, dass man das auch gut kann, und auf der anderen Seite aber auch, um zu schauen, was sind die Tricks, die da angewendet werden. Damit man dem Redner auch irgendwie entgegentreten kann und seine Tricks irgendwie entlarven kann.
Und wer hat das auseinandergenommen?
Ja, da gibt es entsprechende große Rhetoriker, die dann auch so Schulen geprägt haben. Ein ganz bekannter Name ist Demostinis, ein griechischer Rhetoriker, der auch dadurch bekannt geworden ist, dass er viele praktische Tipps gegeben hat, die ihm dann oft noch zugeschrieben werden. Und bis heute, also jeder kennt das mit dem Kieselstein. Also man sagt...
Ich kenne das nicht.
Ja, gut, also da gibt es eine Methode, wie man gut reden kann, also wie man das auch gut hinbekommt, dann die Rede vorzutragen. Dem musst du jetzt empfiehlt, dass man einen Kieselstein in den Mund nehmen soll, um zu üben. Also deutlich zu sprechen. Ja, dann hat man ein Hindernis im Mund und muss halt sehr, sehr deutlich sprechen, damit man überhaupt noch verstanden wird. Und wenn man das einmal mit dem Kieselstein macht, wenn man den dann wegnimmt, dann geht es besonders gut.
Also hast du das schon mal ausprobiert?
Nein, das ist auch nicht zu empfehlen. Also don't do that at home. Also Kieselsteine empfehlen sich nicht. Es wird in der Regel gesagt, man soll einen Korken zwischen die Zähne nehmen und das dann auspeilen.
Einen Korken?
Einen Korken.
Was ist hier mit so kleinen...
Ja, so lange war es nicht verschluckt. Also irgendwas zwischen die Zähne nehmen. Und dann versuchen zu sprechen.
Dass er reden kann.
Das soll man nur zum Üben nehmen, weil das dann natürlich nicht gut klingt. Und wenn man es dann rausnimmt, dann wird das eben wirklich gut. Ja, genau. Und eigentlich gibt er noch mehr Tipps, die aber nicht so überliefert sind wie die Sache mit dem Kieselstein. Also er sagt auch, man soll am Meer stehen, am Ursaal.
Was heißt, die sind nicht so überliefert, die sind nicht mehr so bekannt? Oder ist es nicht gesichert, dass er die gesagt hat?
Nein, das wird ihm alles zugeschrieben, diese Dinge. Aber es wird ihm mehr zugeschrieben, als nur die Sache mit dem Kieselstein. Aber der Kieselstein ist halt irgendwie, jeder sagt, ja, der Kieselstein und so, da muss man das machen. Aber er sagt eben auch, dass man gegen das Meer sprechen soll, also sogar das Ufer in das Meeres stellen und dann gegen das Meer ansprechen.
Wenn man das Meer überzeugt und es sich zurückzieht, dann hat man gewonnen.
Genau, wenn man einfach das Meer übertönen kann.
Also rein lautstärkemäßig.
Es geht darum, laut zu sprechen gegen das Meer oder gegen den Wind. Ja, und dann soll man vor dem Spiegel üben.
Das ist auch ein echtes Problem, laut zu reden. Also ich merke das ja auch immer hier bei den Aufnahmen, wie unterschiedlich laut verschiedene Sprecher sind. Und dasselbe, wenn man das Gefühl hat, jemand bemüht sich, dass da trotzdem irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, der Pegel einfach nicht zuckt. Denkst du, dass das quasi so eine medizinische Veranlagung, also so eine körperliche Veranlagung ist, dass man nicht laut redet, oder ist das dann auch so eine antrainierte Geschichte?
Also es gibt Unterschiede natürlich zwischen Leuten. Also manche sprechen automatisch lauter. Das hat ja auch was mit dem Körperbau zu tun, aber das kann man auch trainieren.
Hast du das mal trainiert?
Nein, das hab ich nicht trainiert. Heute ist das auch nicht mehr so wichtig, weil es da auch Mikrofone gibt und so, die gab's ja früher nicht. Und da musste man das wirklich trainieren. Es wird ja auch zum Beispiel gesagt über August Bebel, den SPD-Politiker am Anfang des 20. Jahrhunderts, dass der eigentlich ein schlechter Redner war, aber dass er sehr laut sprechen konnte. Und deshalb konnte er eben auf Massenveranstaltungen sprechen. Man hatte keine Lautsprecher und der konnte die ganze Masse übertönen. Und das sei der Grund für seine politische Karriere gewesen. Also nicht, dass er gut reden kann, aber er konnte halt laut reden. Und damals war das halt sehr wichtig. Da konnte man nicht mit Mikrofonen auf Versammlungen sprechen. Da musste man also vor Hunderten von Leuten, oder sogar vor Tausenden, ohne Mikrofon sprechen. Und die mussten alle was hören.
Aber wenn man es jetzt nur auf Lautstärke anlegt, das kann heute, ich weiß nicht, ich würde das ja eher als kontraproduktiv ansehen.
Heute ist es kontraproduktiver, wenn man Mikrofone hat. Genau.
Also auch so, sagen wir mal, innerhalb eines Raums, wenn jetzt Leute einfach... Gut, vielleicht ist es meistens auch nur der Trend, dass die Leute dann nicht nur laut reden, sondern dass sie auch zu viel reden. Nicht so richtig aufhören. Ich denke, das ist auch noch mal so ein Punkt. So dieses, wann hält man besser das Maul?
Genau.
Das scheint mir die höchste Kunst überhaupt zu sein.
Genau. Naja, es gibt dann noch die Sache mit der Atemtechnik. Denn man sollte ja vielleicht auch natürlich nicht zu lange Sätze sagen, aber man sollte einen gewissen Satzbogen auch in einem Atemzug sagen können. Das ist auch nicht so einfach. Auch das muss man üben.
Dass man keine Pause macht, die dann eigentlich nicht hätte da sein sollen.
Genau. Also die Pause an den falschen Stellen, das ist immer ganz schlecht. Da erkennt man auch sofort einen schlechten Redner.
Ja.
Auch wenn Redner ablesen und noch nicht wissen, wie lang der Satz ist, da machen sie plötzlich eine Pause irgendwo mitten drin zwischen Präpositionen und dem, was dahinter kommt, wo es gar nicht passt. Und das ist furchtbar für den Hörer.
Da hat man vor allem den Eindruck, dass derjenige gar nicht weiß, wovon er redet.
Genau. Naja, und deshalb sollen wir also ein bisschen sich in Atem...
Aber jetzt sind wir schon weg von Demosthenes.
Doch, doch. Das ist auch noch. Artentechnik ist ganz wichtig. Demosthenes empfiehlt oder so wird ihm zugeschrieben, dass man bergwandert.
Ach.
Und beim Bergwandern eben sich an langem atmen.
Ah, also quasi Ausdauer.
Ja.
Sprich, Sport treiben, wenn man es mal auf die heutige Zeit übertreibt.
Heute würde man wahrscheinlich ins Fitnessstudio gehen und nicht mehr bergwandern.
Aber ja, da ist natürlich was dran.
Ja.
Wenn man so kurz atmig drauf ist, abgesehen davon, dass irgendwann die Lunge flötet, kann man dann einfach auch nicht so die Stamina dann einfach mal die Sätze zu Ende bringen. Auf der anderen Seite sind ja nun lange Sätze auch nicht unbedingt gerade immer zu empfehlen.
Nee, das ist gerade nicht zu empfehlen. Aber wenn man das mit der Atemtechnik gut raus hat, dann macht man auch automatisch nicht allzu lange Sätze, nämlich gerade so lange Sätze, wie man atmen kann. Und wenn man kurz atmig ist, dann hängt man eins ans andere und dann wird der Satz endlos. Es gibt noch mehr Tipps von dem Ostinist, den Spiegel, hatte ich schon genannt, dass man vor dem Spiegel redet, damit das auch mit der Gestik und der Mimik stimmt, denn das Auge hört hier mit.
Aber woran erkennt man, dass man da die richtige Gestik an den Tag legt? Aber es ist eine gute. Also für wie wichtig würdest du die Gestik einschätzen?
Also ganz wichtig, ganz wichtig. Kann man sehr schön sehen, wenn man sich Bundestagsreden anschaut bei YouTube. Da sieht man z.B. Sarah Wagenknecht, die von der Struktur der Rede her eigentlich gute Reden hält. Allerdings bereitet sie sie vor und liest sie dann ab. Und da ist dann das Problem, also inhaltlich, was heißt inhaltlich, also von der Form der Rede sehr gut. Aber sie steht dann da, klammert sich fest am Podium und dann redet sie. Das ist irgendwie zu statisch. Also sie müsste die Hände wegnehmen vom Podium und mal was machen mit den Händen. Ja, da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Also zur Unterstreichung von wichtigen Dingen, irgendwann mal die Hand hochheben oder so. Wenn man etwas ablehnt, dann vielleicht auch so eine ablehnende Geste oder so. Also dass man eben das, was man sagt, irgendwie mit Gesten unterstreicht. Das ist sehr gut. Also wenn man unter vier Augen spricht, ist es manchmal etwas lächerlich. Also wenn ich jetzt genauer rumfuchtel, das machen die Italiener ja so, die machen das ja sogar am Telefon. Das finde ich immer so witzig. Also gut, ich darf nicht allgemein haben, nicht alle Italiener, aber ich kenne Italiener. Also ein guter Freund von mir, der telefoniert jeden Abend mit seiner Mutter, das ist dann irgendwie vorgeschrieben, um 22.30 Uhr oder so. Dann ruft er bei seiner Mutter an. Und das macht er natürlich egal, wo er gerade ist. Und dann sieht man ihn am Handy und dann furtelt er mit der anderen Hand und manchmal sogar mit dem Handy noch rum, während er mit seiner Mutter spricht, obwohl die das ja gar nicht sehen kann.
Ich glaube, das ist mir neulich auch passiert. Also gerade, wenn man eine Freisprecheinrichtung benutzt, also hier Mikrofon am Kopfhörerkabel zum Beispiel und dann rumläuft. Ich finde aber auch, die Bewegung ist manchmal sehr hilfreich, um überhaupt reden zu können. Ich habe mir neulich mal, glaube ich, eine halbe Stunde mit einem Freund telefoniert, mit dem ich schon lange nicht mehr gesprochen hatte. Und ich bin dann einfach rausgegangen. Und ich bin, glaube ich, während dieses gesamten Telefongesprächs hier drei Kilometer durch die Stadt gelaufen. Das Wetter hat es halt hergegeben. Und ich habe keine Ahnung, wie viel ich rumgefuchtelt habe. Aber das hat definitiv geholfen.
Genau, also das ist sicherlich ganz wichtig, dass man da sich auch bewegt und was dazu macht. Man kann dann wahrscheinlich auch seine Gedanken klarer rüberbringen. Und das auch noch mit einer Geste unterstreicht.
Ich finde das auch mal ganz furchtbar. Bei vielen Vortragssituationen gibt es ja immer dieses Podium. Das ist ja auch eine Erfindung der Griechen. Am besten dann noch mit so einem Fest-Mikrofon, wo man dann quasi schon mal so hingenagelt wird, so du stehst da jetzt und machst das. Und ich lehne das eigentlich immer ab, wenn es nicht anders geht. Aber wenn sich vermeiden lässt, dann bevorzuge ich immer Funk-Mikrofone. Einfach genau wie du sagst, dass man einfach den Ausdruck geben kann, die Positionen verändern kann, um die Gestik zu unterstreuen.
Selbst am Rednerpult ist das besser mit dem freien Mikrofon, weil man sich dann auch mal zurückbewegen kann. Das ist deutlich besser, als wenn man da an so einem Mikrofon hängt und da nicht weg kann. Also ich meine gute Mikrofonanlagen, wie zum Beispiel im Bundestag, die sind natürlich so ausgelegt, dass man sich durchaus auch mal wegbewegen kann.
Die sind fantastisch, die will ich auch haben. Da bin ich immer total überrascht, wie sehr die da hin und her wackeln können. Und es klingt trotzdem auch noch perfekt.
Ja, aber sowas ist halt teuer und das hat man nicht immer. Die müssen ja völlig in die Architektur eingepasst werden. Da müssen ja entsprechend auch Dicken abgesenkt werden. Das kann man sich einfach sonst nicht leisten. Also schon im Abgeordnetenhaus, haben wir ja gesehen, ist das deutlich schlechter.
Gut, also Demosthenes hat sich auf jeden Fall eine Menge Gedanken gemacht und allerlei Ratschläge gegeben.
Da fehlt noch ein Tipp, den man auch nennen kann, weil du nach dem Podium gefragt hast. Also in der Antike hatte man keine Podien, also nicht so, wie wir das heute haben. Also ein Podium schon, also die Leute standen erhöht. In Rom gab es dann auch extra so eine Art Empore, wo man sich draufstellte. Also der Redner sollte erhöht stehen, damit ihn auch alle sehen können und gut hören können. Aber man sprach halt immer frei. Also man legte nirgendswo sein Manuskript ab. Also das Konzept des Manuskripts war halt schwierig in der Antike. Da hatte man nicht so die Möglichkeit, schnell mal was auf Papier zu schreiben und da hinzulegen.
Der Laserdrucker war noch nicht erfunden.
Genau. Und außerdem gerade die Leute, die dann im Senat auftraten. Senat ist ja die Versammlung der Alten. Also die waren dann meistens über 40. So alt wurde man ja in der Antike auch nicht. Das heißt, sie waren alle altersweitsichtig. Die konnten überhaupt nichts mehr ablesen. Das heißt, sie mussten notgedrungen ihre Rede frei halten. Und da gab es natürlich dann noch besondere Schwierigkeiten. Vor allen Dingen, wenn man draußen ist. Also zum Beispiel auf der Agorá. Da ist es manchmal windig. Und der Redner muss natürlich auch gut angezogen sein. Und dann trägt man also in der Antike meist eine Toga. Diese Toga flattert eventuell im Wind. Das heißt, die muss man dann auch noch festhalten. Also es gab dann auch viele Schwierigkeiten. Und deshalb sagt die Mostel, dass man immer reden, üben mit einer Lanze über der Schulter.
Mit einer Lanze?
Ja. Denn dann muss man was festhalten und kriegt trotzdem das irgendwie hin, mit der anderen Hand Gesten zu machen. Und hat halt diese Behinderung schon, die kommt, wenn dann ein Windstoß kommt.
Also was heute sozusagen das Handy ist, das war so damals die Lanze.
Genau, weil dann ein Windstoß kommt und so. Das muss man halt alles üben. Und deshalb soll man also versuchen, also sich selber noch eine Behinderung, also nicht nur eine durch den Kieselstein im Mund, sondern auch noch eine Behinderung zuzufügen, dass man halt irgendwann noch was tragen muss, damit man eben noch besser redet. Und wenn man die dann weglässt, dann ist man natürlich noch freier und macht auch noch bessere Gesten.
Also wenn man sich quasi mit einem Bäuchchen im Mund, mit dem Handy am Ohr eine große Straßenkreuzung stellt, dann hat man quasi die urbane Version der Neuzeit von Demosthenes hergestellt. Und wenn man es richtig gut machen will, dann stellt man sich neben die Autobahn.
Genau. Und wenn man da dann gut ist, dann geht man in die Bundestag und kann das auch bei der tollen Mikrofonanlage ohne Giesel schneiden.
Verstehe. Also man stellt sich auf so eine Autobahnbrücke und wenn die ersten zehn Autos stehen geblieben sind, dann kann man sich schon mal zur Wahl anmelden lassen. Finde ich aber schon mal ganz gut, weil das vor allem auch so entkoppelt ist jetzt erstmal von dem, was man eigentlich sagt. Ja, aber ich denke, das bemerke ich auch sehr häufig, dass Leute, die eigentlich auch was wissen, die theoretisch eine Menge mitzuteilen hätten, dann einfach eben an so einfachen Sachen scheitern. An so einer Zersplitterung ihrer Redeweise, dass nur der Kurzatmigkeit geschuldet ist oder einfach nur der mangelnden Konzentration kann ich dann immer nicht sagen. Und dann natürlich auch die Lautstärke. Und welche Bedeutung hat der so dieser Demosthenes? Also sind dann alle so zu ihm hin gepilgert und haben sich da irgendwie einen Workshop eintragen lassen?
Genau, also es gab halt diese Redner-Schulen überall. Also nicht nur Demosthenes, sondern das machte man eben und ließ sich dann eben ausbilden. Also es gehörte eben dazu, wenn man halt irgendwie zu einer besseren Familie gehörte, wo es dann auch darum ging, irgendwie Verantwortung zu übernehmen, dann war es also ganz normal, dass man sich eben in gutem Reden ausbilden ließ.
Okay. Und da hieß das dann auch schon Rhetorik?
Daher kommt ja der Name.
Und ist dann damals schon alles erfunden worden? Ich meine, gut, was hatte denn Demosthenes? Da ist ja jetzt inhaltlich noch sozusagen gar nichts. War denn inhaltlich die Sache dann auch schon?
Ja, also das, was man da lernte, also dieser Kanon, der ist ja auch schon in der Antike direkt festgelegt worden, worum es dann ging in der Rhetorik. Also Kanon ist jetzt das Programm, das Programm, was man zu lernen hatte, oder die Bereiche des Programms. Die waren schon in Griechenland festgelegt, die sind eigentlich so geblieben. Also selbst heute, wenn man sich irgendein Buch über Rhetorik kauft, dann findet man immer wieder die gleiche Einteilung. Also eine Sache ist ein bisschen zurückgenommen, klar. Also ein wichtiger Punkt aus dieser antiken Einteilung ist die Memorierung der Rede. Das wird heute in den Rhetorik-Büchern nicht mehr so vermittelt, leider, muss ich sagen.
Also sich merken, was man sagen will. Genau. Das was Schauspieler aber immer noch tun müssen.
Ja, das machen Schauspieler, aber das machen Redner nicht mehr so. Das ist ein Problem, denke ich. Es gibt viele Redner, die hängen dann an ihrem Manuskript und das ist dann nicht wirklich gut.
Was gehört zu diesem Kanon?
Also diesem Kanon gehören fünf Punkte. Also dass das fünf Punkte sind, ist auch kein Zufall. Da können wir nachher noch mal drauf kommen. Es gibt nämlich immer diese Schematat, dass man drei Punkte hat oder fünf Punkte. Das hängt damit zusammen, dass man in der Antike schon herausgefunden hat, dass man sich Dinge besonders gut merken kann, wenn sie in einer bestimmten Zahl auftreten. Also wenn es eine Gruppierung gibt von drei oder fünf. Und dass die auch gut funktionieren, wenn man irgendwie redet und eine Einteilung macht. Weil irgendwie kognitiv man sich beim Zuhören gerade mal so drei Sachen gut merken kann oder fünf Sachen gut merken kann, mehr aber nicht.
Echt? Fünf Sachen kann man sich besser merken als vier?
Offenbar, ja.
Das ist ja schon ein diskordischer Ansatz.
Ich kann mal diese fünf Punkte nennen. Also Law of Five, da haben wir es. Also das ist erstmal die Gedankenfindung. Man muss lernen, Gedanken zu finden.
Also überhaupt jetzt mal zu wissen, worüber man reden will.
Genau. Und dann muss man die anordnen. Das nächste Thema ist dann die Gedankenanordnung. Also wie ordne ich zum Beispiel meine Argumente an in der Rede? Da gibt es ja verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Chronologisch, nach Überzeugungskraft und so. Da gibt es ganz interessante Ideen dazu. Der dritte Punkt ist dann die Versprachlichung der Rede. Also ich muss ja meine Gedanken versprachlichen, muss also irgendwie eine Rede draus machen aus meinen Gedanken. Das ist natürlich der wichtigste Punkt, denn da kann man dann mögliche Tricks einbauen. Der vierte Punkt ist dann der, der heute vernachlässigt wird, die Memorierung. Also ich sage leider vernachlässigt, weil das besser wäre, wenn viel mehr Leute frei redeten. Und der fünfte Punkt ist dann der eigentliche Vortrag. Also wie trage ich gut vor?
Was wir jetzt schon teilweise auch angesprochen haben.
Das haben wir jetzt schon angesprochen. Wir haben also von hinten angefangen.
Na dann fangen wir doch vielleicht nochmal vorne an. Also Gedanken finden, kann man das so üben? Ich meine, sind das jetzt nicht nur so die Ideen, die man so hat? Was macht jetzt diesen Prozess da so definierbar?
Na ja doch, man muss halt überlegen. Also es ist der ganze Bereich der Planung und der Konzeption. Also die Gedankenordnung ist natürlich auch Planung und Konzeption. Aber erst mal muss man sich überlegen, was gehört alles zu meinem Thema? Welche Aspekte spreche ich an? Das machen wir hier beim Podcast auch. Wir sitzen da erst mal und machen so ein Brainstorming mit Stichwörtern, was wir alles sagen wollen. Und das sollte man tun. Also man sollte erst mal überlegen, was ist denn jetzt alles wichtig? Was sollte alles noch angesprochen werden? Und dann kommen einem vielleicht auch erst die guten Ideen, was man überhaupt alles noch bringen kann zu seinem Thema.
Also quasi Stichworte sammeln.
Genau.
Und die auch erst mal so loseblattmäßig vor sich ausbreiten.
Naja, loseblattmäßig macht man ja nicht mehr. Heute hat man ja Outliner und Mind-Maps und so. Und gerade bei Outliner und Mind-Maps.
Das ist ja auch digitale loseblatze.
Ja, da ist ja das Tolle, dass man anschließend alles verschieben kann. Das ist dann der zweite Punkt mit der Gedankenordnung. Aber erst mal alles rein.
Ja, deswegen meinte ich ja gerade loseblatze haben. Was ich ja generell, unabhängig jetzt auch von Rhetorik, so eine der tollsten Kulturtechniken, die ich so erarbeitet habe, kann ich jetzt gerade nicht demonstrieren, weil sie mir gerade ausgegangen sind, aber ich habe so DIN-A6-Karten. Also so Postkarten-Format und auch so diese Stärke, aber einfach so als Weiß-Karton. In der Regel jetzt gerade nicht, immer griffbereit, einfach, um da so Dinge drauf schreiben zu können. Und teilweise auch mal nur so eine Sache, so auf so einem Zettel. Dann kann man die nämlich immer so richtig schön shuffeln, neu ordnen, quasi in eine Reihenfolge bringen, etc. Das könnte sicherlich da auch mal ganz hilfreich sein.
Ja, also ich benutze ja gerne so Mind-Maps. Also ich habe ja früher, als man das noch auf Papier gemacht hat, das immer für sehr seltsam gehalten. Aber jetzt mit so mobilen kleinen Geräten, da geht das ganz gut. Da kann man sich mal so ein Stichwort aufschreiben und dann hinterher das zurecht schieben.
Mit Mind-Maps bin ich bisher noch nicht so klargekommen. Was würdest du meinen, ist da so das entscheidende Element, was jetzt das hilfreich macht?
Also gerade, dass man das eben, das ist eben der tolle Programm auf...
Also ich meine, welche Funktionalität kriegst du da, die es dir jetzt einfacher macht?
Ja, man gibt einfach irgendwie Stichworte ein, die einem einfallen und dann schiebt man sich die zurecht und ordnet die in eine Hierarchie. Also oft ist ja so, dass einem irgendwas einfällt und dann nach und nach denkt man, ja das passt ja zu dem und dann kann man Gruppen bilden. Also ich nutze das zum Beispiel, wenn ich irgendwie selber Mitschriften mache. Man kann ja gerade auf so einem mobilen Gerät nicht so viel schreiben. Das heißt, man kann immer nur so einzelne Stichwörter schreiben oder vielleicht mal einen Link, wenn irgendwie jemand sagt, ja da steht doch da und da im Internet, kann man diesen Link gleich dazu tun. Und dann kann man im hinterher auch noch oder während der Mensch noch spricht, Sachen eben noch zusammenfügen und Querverbindungen aufzeichnen und so. Und dann erschließt sich das, was gesagt wird, eigentlich sehr schön. Und wie gesagt, für mich selbst mache ich das auch. Also regelmäßig zur Vorbereitung eines Podcasts setze ich mich hin und in der Regel mit meinem Gesprächspartner. Und dann sagt er irgendwas, dann schreibe ich da erstmal ein Stichwort auf und dann überlege ich mir, was passt denn wie zusammen. Und dann ergeben sich automatisch dann so Gruppen und man hat dann so eine Abfolge, die man dann aber noch während des Podcasts ändern kann. Also wenn der plötzlich zu einem anderen Thema springt, kann ich auf meiner Mind-Map das einfach verschieben und dann weiß ich immer noch, was kommt. Außerdem nutze ich da auch noch bei meinem Tool die Farben. Das heißt also ich kann dann eben Sachen umfärben. Das kann ich kombinieren. Also wenn ich Sachen nach oben schiebe, dann werden die, da gibt es so eine Regenbogenfunktion, dann gehen die in den roten Bereich und wenn ich Sachen nach unten schiebe, dann gehen die in den blauen Bereich und ich weiß halt, was noch nicht rot ist, kommt noch.
Sehr schön, mit Farben. Ja, bei mir sind das so kleine Checkboxen, aber im Wesentlichen ist es ähnlich. Ich wollte da gerade einhalten, weil natürlich gerade im Dialog, und ich weiß jetzt nicht, inwiefern die Rhetorik sich eigentlich vor allem dem Monolog widmet, zumindest dem kurzzeitigen Monolog, oder auch so Dialogisches genauso abfasst, aber wie du schon richtig sagst, merke ich auch immer wieder bei Gesprächen, so ein Gespräch will halt auch manchmal entwischen. Und wenn man dann nämlich zu sehr so eine Abfolge dann frönt und sich quasi zum Sklaven seiner Ordnung macht, dann zerstört man natürlich auch schnell die Dynamik eines Dialogs. Und das ist dann wiederum kontraproduktiv.
Und deshalb sollte man eben auch bei der Vorbereitung Gedankenfindung, Gedankenordnung trennen. Denn sonst kommt man immer in so einen engen Pass rein, weil man dann nur noch in der Richtung denkt, ich bin gerade an der Stelle, ich muss in die Richtung. Sondern erstmal frei assoziieren, sozusagen das Brainstorming machen und dann gucken, wie passt das denn zusammen.
Okay, das sind also die ersten beiden Schritte. Jetzt wird es spannend. Versprachlichungen hast du gesagt. Ja, also quasi so von den Gedanken hin zu dem konkret zu Sagenden.
Genau. Naja, wir haben noch vielleicht bei der Gedanken, wir sollten vielleicht auch noch was zur Gedankenordnung sagen. Da bist du jetzt ein bisschen schnell drüber weggegangen.
Okay.
Da muss man ja auch noch sehen, wie baue ich dann das zusammen, wenn ich es versprachliche, also bevor ich es versprachliche. Was ist da so die Abfolge? Und da gibt es eben auch Tipps dieser langen Bekannt-Sin, also auch schon seit der Antike. Bei der Argumentation, wenn ich die Argumente ordne, ist es immer gut, mit einem relativ starken Argument anzufangen, dann schwächere Argumente zu bringen und zum Schluss dann noch mal ein sehr starkes Argument zu bringen. Das hat was mit der Aufmerksamkeit zu tun. Also heute kann man das natürlich alles psychologisch untersuchen. Das konnte man natürlich in Griechenland auch nicht, aber das hatte man schon gemerkt. Erstmal ein starkes Argument, um die Aufmerksamkeit zu wecken, dann die schwächeren Argumente, weil die nicht so im Gedächtnis bleiben und zum Schluss dann das sehr starke, weil das am besten im Gedächtnis bleibt. Das ist immer auch so eine ganz wichtige Grundregel, die auch bis heute gilt, aber die kommt eben schon aus der griechischen Rhetorik.
Sprich, man eröffnet erst mal so mit der Trompete und alle werden wach, weil das so ein Argument ist, was sich allen erschließt.
Bei der Abfolge der Argumente, also man fängt nicht so die Rede an. Im Mittelteil der Rede gibt es halt den Bereich der Argumentation und da sollte erst ein richtig schlages Argument kommen und während die Leute sich noch gedanklich daran abarbeiten, bringt man die schwächeren Argumente und dann zum Schluss das sehr starke Argument und das bleibt dann hängen.
So hat der Motto, ja, das kann man sich ja gar nicht anders vorstellen.
Genau, also das empfiehlt sich, diese Reihenfolge zu wählen. Natürlich kann man andere Reihenfolgen wählen, das hängt ja auch so ein bisschen vom Thema ab. Aber im Großen und Ganzen sollte man auf jeden Fall vermeiden, das schwächste Argument zum Schluss zu bringen. Denn dann hängen sich alle an dem auf und dann ist man gleich auf der Verliererseite. So und der Gesamtaufbau der Rede ist halt auch schon seit Alten festgelegt und interessant ist, dass das immer noch so ist, wenn man sich jetzt reden anschaut, funktioniert das immer noch so. Am Anfang gibt es so etwas, das nennt sich captatio benevolentiae auf Lateinisch. Also das Erfassen des Wohlwollens. Also man versucht, den Hörer oder den Gesprächspartner für sich einzunehmen, also gewogen zu machen. Also es ist eine Begrüßung, in dem man den irgendwie anspricht. In dem man vielleicht auch einen kleinen Witz macht am Anfang. Das ist immer ganz gut. Dann ist das heiß sozusagen, gebrochen.
Sind wir jetzt schon in diesen dritten Teil vorgestoßen?
Nein, nein, wir sind immer noch beim Aufbau. Die bau ich also auf.
Okay, also bis ins Detail sozusagen. Jetzt gar nicht mehr nur so eine ganz grobe Struktur, sondern schon jeder kleinste Teil.
Genau, also naja, was heißt jeder kleinste Teil? Jeder kleinste Teil, das ist dann immer diese gleiche Abfolge. Also erstmal die Begrüßung, die eigentlich gar nicht zur Rede gehört. Also so ein Einstieg, vielleicht ein Witz vorher, der wirklich gar nicht dazugehört oder dass man wenigstens sagt, mit wem man spricht, dass das der Extremfall ist, dass jemand sagt, Herr Präsident, meine Damen und Herren, und dann geht's erst los. Also man versucht die Leute erst mal gewogen zu machen, das wird ritualisiert im Parlament. Dann sagen sie immer nur Herr Präsident, meine Damen und Herren. Genau, das ist natürlich auch eine schöne Rede, was du da gerade ansprichst. Das ist ja auch so ein richtiges Muster. Die Rede von Marcos Antonios nach dem Tod Cäsars. Die ist nicht original, da weiß man auch nicht so richtig, was da passiert ist. Original. Da gibt es Überlieferungen bei den Antiken Historikern, dass Marcos Antonios den blutbefleckten Mantel Cäsars hochgehalten haben soll. Das weiß man nicht so genau. Shakespeare erfindet das neu in seinem Theaterstück und macht da eine vorbildliche Rede, die interessant ist, weil sie sehr viele rhetorische Mittel enthält und genauso losgeht. Das wird erst einmal diese Begrüßungsformel gemacht, wo er die Römer als seine Freunde, also Römer-Landsleute, für sich einnehmen will. Also Friends from Countryman. Dann geht er auch auf sich ein. Dann gibt es immer dieses Wiederkehrende, dass er sagt, dass Brutus ein ehrenwerter Bürger ist. Was dann aber immer weniger passt. Das wird dann immer ironischer zum Schluss. Das ist halt das Hauptmittel. Aber auf die Mittel wollte ich noch kommen. Ich wollte noch was zum Aufbau sagen.
Friends from Countryman, lend me your ears. So ist der offizielle Mitglied.
Genau. Und dann sagt er ja auch, worum es geht. Das ist dann das nächste, was man bringen sollte. Da geht es jetzt los. Also nach der Begrüßung haben wir wieder drei Teile. Da haben wir wieder diese Dreiteiligkeit. Also man sagt, worum es geht zunächst. Dann kommt die Argumentation und dann kommt ein Schluss. Und am Schluss, das ist ganz, ganz wichtig, da muss immer etwas kommen, was in Erinnerung bleibt. Also heute würde man sagen, irgendwas, was twitterbar ist. Na ja, das ist ganz, ganz wichtig. Wenn am Ende irgendwie so was Allgemeines kommt, wie kürzlich da, das habe ich in meinem Vortrag auf den Kongress gebracht, das Ende der Rede von Westerwelle, so was völlig Allgemeines, dann verpufft alles, da ist dann nichts mehr da. Das ist ganz falsch. Also am Ende muss irgendwas kommen, was bleibt.
Ein Kongressvortrag, das soll ich mal kurz erwähnen, ging um?
Da ging es um Nebelsprech, also der Nebel in der Sprache der Politik. Also wie man mit Sprache Nebel erzeugt. Genau, das ist jetzt sehr aktuell und da kommt eben Nebel in der Rede von Westerwelle, weil am Ende nichts mehr sagt. Da kommen nur noch allgemeinen Plätze und das ist schlecht. Also am Ende muss irgendwie was bleiben, was in Erinnerung bleibt. Also irgend so ein letzter Paukenschlag oder so, oder so ein Satz bei der Kennedy-Rede, die wir uns vielleicht noch ein bisschen näher anschauen. Es ist ja so, dass er am Ende dann nochmal sagt, ich bin ein Berliner. Also das sagt er schon am Anfang, damit geht es los. Und am Ende dann nochmal und das bleibt dann eben tatsächlich in Erinnerung. Also solch eine Kreisstruktur ist auch sehr häufig. In jedem Fall am Ende was wirklich in Erinnerung bleibt, also am besten was Twitterbares.
Ich twitter das gleich mal, dass ich ein Berliner bin.
Naja, aber wie gesagt, das ist eben das, was im Gedächtnis bleibt, was zum Schluss kommt. Deshalb ist es ganz, ganz wichtig, dass man da eben auch nochmal alles zusammennimmt und noch was Schönes sagt, was dann auch gleich zitiert wird. Das ist ja dann auch für die Zeitung wichtig. Die kann das gleich zitieren.
Also Gedanken finden, klar, Stichworte sammeln, etc. Dann Gedanken ordnen, einfach einerseits klar machen, worüber man eigentlich reden will. Also das sollte man quasi auch an den Anfang stellen und auch explizit benennen. Also man sollte sagen, ich möchte heute reden über la la la. Meine Aufgabe hier ist das und das. Also man nennt quasi das Thema. Kurz, knackig. Oder lohnt es sich dann auch weiter auszuholen? Nur damit klar ist, dass die Erwartung einfach klar ist. Okay, und dann geht man in die Argumente und die Argumente bringen man am besten so vor, dass die Leute einem nicht einschlafen. Das heißt, mit irgendwas, was schon mal einleuchtend ist, als stark wahrgenommen wird. Danach schiebt man die ganzen Feinigkeiten nach, die fallen dann nicht so auf. Und am Ende kommt der Tweet.
Nee, nee, am Ende kommt das starke Argument. Und dann kommt zum Schluss vielleicht das starke Argument, nochmal als Tweet. Das Argument selber ist vielleicht komplexer und man kann das nicht so gut fittern.
Okay, klar. Versteh schon. So, und dann eben als Abschluss der Argumentation oder eben dann im Nachgang, da geht's dann nur jetzt darum, noch in Erinnerung zu bleiben? Oder ist zum Beispiel eine Zusammenfassung der Argumente, wäre das schon mal noch ein guter Schluss? Oder ergibt sich das einfach durch die Reihung? Also es ist...
Eine Zusammenfassung, weiß ich nicht. Also es sollte irgendwie noch so eine Art Knaller sein. Also die Zusammenfassung kann dann schnell sehr langweilig werden. Also es sollte wirklich kurz und bündig sein. Es geht nicht nur um die Erinnerung. Es geht ja auch darum, dass man irgendwie anzeigen will, jetzt bin ich am Ende. Und man will Applaus, also als Redner. Und wenn dann irgendwas Komisches am Ende ist, dann kriegt man halt, sieht man auch sehr schön bei der Westerwelle Rede, dann gibt es dann nur gelangweilten Applaus. Wenn aber am Ende irgendwie noch so ein Knaller kommt, dann sind die Leute begeistert und klatschen mehr. Das will man ja als Redner auch.
Was ist ein Knaller? Ich bin ein Berliner Wanker.
Ja, zum Beispiel, ja. Gibt es viele andere.
Ist die Rede jetzt so besonders, diese von Kennedy?
Ja, ich glaube, die ist besonders, weil sie sehr viele, also weil sie mustergültig ist. Das passt genau in sozusagen ins Lehrbuch. Da wird die auch immer benutzt, um zu zeigen, hier, so macht man es.
Kann man das mal festmachen an irgendwas?
Naja, man kann es an vielen Dingen festmachen.
Nach dem, was du jetzt gesagt hast, müsste er jetzt eigentlich seine Rede, ich kann sie nicht auswendig wiedergeben, müsste er sie ja quasi erst mal mit diesem ich will reden über...
Ja, sagt er ja. Na ja, er fängt mit dem Grund, also erst kommt diese Cartazio Benevolenz, wo er sich halt hier praktisch die Leute begrüßt. Aber er sagt nicht, sehr geehrter Herr Bürgermeister, sehr geehrter Herr Kanzler, Honorationen, Exzellenzen. Sondern er bringt das in so einen Text rein, wo man irgendwie...
Was sagt er denn? Sag mal.
Ja, hast du es nicht zum Abspielen da am Anfang? Also ich kann es auch sagen.
Ja, sag mal.
Also er sagt, ich bin... Also I'm proud to come to the city, also ich bin stolz darauf, in diese Stadt als Gast ihres, äh, ja, Distinguished Mayor zu kommen. Und dann gleich, dass er den Kampfgeist Westberlins repräsentiert, also wird ihm auch noch ein Kompliment gemacht. Dann der Distinguished Chancellor, der Deutschland eben auf Demokratie, Freiheit und Fortschritt ausgerichtet hat. Auch diese Dreiergruppe, Demokratie, Freiheit und Fortschritt, ist natürlich was, worauf wir noch kommen werden bei der Versprachlichung. Und dann zum Schluss eben General Clay, der dann auch noch mal charakterisiert wird, dass ihm in der Krise geholfen hat. Und dann sogar noch diese implizite Drohung, er kommt wieder, wenn es nötig ist. So, das ist die Kapitale Art für Medivolenz. Die gehören gar nicht dazu zu reden, sondern die soll erstmal so eine allgemeine Begrüßung machen und eben die Hörer für sich einnehmen. Klar, wenn man, the fighting spirit of West-Berlin, da freuen sich natürlich die Berliner und klatschen ja auch entsprechend. Das sieht man auch sehr schön. Er spricht sehr langsam, er unterbricht auch immer. Das hängt auch damit zusammen, dass das gedolmetscht wird und so. Da sind natürlich auch sehr niedrige Umstände da. Und auch sehr, er spricht auch sehr laut. Das ist eben noch so dieser alte Stil, so würde man das heute vielleicht nicht mehr machen. Ja, und dann geht's eigentlich los. Und dann kommt der Leitgedanke, der am Anfang steht und am Ende. Nämlich der mit der römischen Gedanke, ki vis romanus hum, ich bin ein römischer Bürger. Eben übertragen auf die heutige Zeit, wo man eben als freier Mensch sagt, ich bin ein Berliner. Weil Berlin eben das Symbol der Freiheit ist. Das ist sozusagen der Ausgangspunkt und der Endpunkt seiner Rede. Das gibt da so eine Kreisstruktur. Danach macht er noch diesen Witz, den man gerne am Anfang macht. Er sagt, I appreciate my interpreter translating my German. Er freut sich, dass sein Übersetzer auch sein Deutsch übersetzt. Ich bin ein Berliner, das klingt ja nicht so verständlich. Ja, und dann steigt er wirklich ins Thema ein und sagt das Thema. Er sagt, there are many people in the world who really don't understand or say they don't. What's the great issue between the free world and the communist world? Also was ist der Unterschied zwischen der freien Welt und der kommunistischen Welt? Und dann kommen diese Unterschiede. Er demonstriert dann auch sehr schön das Scheitern des Kommunismus.
Jetzt müsste ja nach deiner Logik erstmal ein starkes Argument kommen.
Ja, das ist ein starker Argument. Er setzt sich mit den Gegnern auseinander, eigentlich zunächst mit den Argumenten der Gegner. Und sagt, da gibt es also Leute, die sagen, dass der Kommunismus schlecht sei oder eben ein böses System. Aber man kann wirtschaftlichen Fortschritt machen. Und das hält er dagegen eigentlich kein wirkliches Argument. Und dann sagt er dann sogar noch auf Deutsch, lasst sie nach Berlin kommen, let them come to Berlin. Also auf Deutsch und Englisch. Also er setzt sich gleich mit diesem Argument auseinander, dass der Kommunismus die Zukunft sei oder dass der Kommunismus böse sei, diese Anschauung. Und dann sagt er, guckt euch das doch in Berlin an. Das ist praktisch sogar kein richtiges Argument.
Aber das ist jetzt schon die starke Komponente, die natürlich dann bei den Leuten gut resoniert.
Ja, klar. Das kommt sehr gut an. Das ist ja ganz auf die Wirkung ausgerichtet. Dann kommen die Schwierigkeiten der Freiheit und der Demokratie. Und dann das Argument, dass eben der Kommunismus dafür sorgt, dass hier Menschen getrennt werden durch die innerdeutsche Grenze und so. Das ist dann vielleicht nicht ganz so ein starkes Argument. Und dann zum Schluss verallgemeinert er eben. Und bringt eben dieses Argument, dass hier eine Insel der Freiheit verteidigt wird, dass aber die Freiheit immer nur dann da ist, wenn alle frei sind. Und das führt dann wieder zu dem Schlusspunkt. All free men wherever they may live are citizens of Berlin. Also alle freien Menschen sind Bürger von Berlin. Und daher als freier Mensch sage ich oder I take pride in the words, ich bin ein Berliner. Und damit haben wir das ganze dann. Also da schließt sich dann der Kreis.
Eine Rede, die ja noch bis heute in dieser Stadt resoniert.
Genau, genau. Ja, es gab ja auch wenig Vergleichbares in dieser Stadt.
Ja, es gab, ja, Ernst Reuter hat ja auch ganz gut gepunktet.
Genau. Auch mit so einem Gedanken, den man twittern konnte. Völker der Welt schaut auf diese Stadt. Und das ist ja genau der Satz, der dann hängen geblieben ist bis heute. Dann ich bin ein Berliner. Ja, dann haben wir die Obama-Rede. Wobei ich von der Obama-Rede jetzt keinen Satz habe, der im Gedächtnis geblieben ist. Na ja, yes we can hat er immer gesagt.
Ja, wobei das, ja, ist das wichtig, dass man so ein, wenn man jetzt mal auch über eine Rede hinausgeht, so ein Brand da quasi sich auch schafft. Ich meine, das hat ja dann auch die Gefahr, dass man sich, dass man wiederholt oder langweilig gilt.
Na, es sollte wenigstens irgendein, irgendwas dabei sein, was so ein bisschen im Gedächtnis bleibt. Das muss ja nicht Jahrzehnte im Gedächtnis bleiben, wie ich bin ein Berliner, oder schaut auf diese Stadt. Aber irgendwie ein Satz, der bleibt.
Aber ich denke, man kann mit Punkt und Recht behaupten, dass Obama auf keinen Fall Präsident gewesen geworden wäre, hätte er nicht diese herausragende sprachliche Begabung. Weil er ist ein guter Redner, unabhängig davon, was man jetzt von ihm selber denkt. Was mir persönlich von ihm am meisten in Erinnerung geblieben ist, außer dass ich grundsätzlich finde, dass er einfach einen schönen Pace hat, seine Geschwindigkeit, die er an den Tag legt, finde ich optimal. Das ist jetzt ein subjektives Empfinden. Ich kann das nicht so auseinandernehmen, wie du das jetzt gemacht hast. Aber ich denke, seine allererste Rede im Hinblick auf eine mögliche kommende Präsidentschaft, wo er auch noch zusätzlich mit Symbolik gearbeitet hat, wo er quasi verkündet hat, dass er überhaupt in den Präsidentschaftsrennen hineingeht, wo er sich quasi als Kandidat vorgestellt hat, wo sein Gegner Salopp bei Letterman dann auf dem Sofa regelt und dann sagt, ich geh jetzt auch in diesen Präsidentschaftswahlkampf. Das war so, wie McCain das gemacht hat. Obama ist ja dann, muss ich mal überlegen, was das war, war das so eine Freiheitsglocke, also irgendein Ort der Verkündigung von irgendwas, die Verfassung kriegst du halt nicht zusammen in Chicago, hat sich halt erstmal an einen symbolträchtigen Platz gestellt und dann quasi in dem Kontext dann auch gleich mitschwingen lassen, so hier ich mein's ernst und ich bin irgendwie der Tradition verbunden. Es ist schon fast eine Pflicht, ich spüre schon fast die Pflicht hier als Präsident zu kandidieren, wer wäre ich, wenn ich das nicht tun würde. Das hat er jetzt so nicht gesagt, ich weiß nicht, was er da gesagt hat, aber so kam es halt auf jeden Fall rüber.
Ja genau, das kann er wirklich gut und da sind dann sicherlich auch, naja, es sind jetzt nicht so diese Sachen, wo man sich dran erinnert, obwohl es auch bei ihm immer diese Catchphrases gibt.
Ich meine dieses Yes, we can, das war ja das. Das hat er in seiner ersten Rede nicht gehabt, aber als er das dann gebracht hat, was ja auch schnell dann diese quasi zu Memen wurde, nicht dann auch von Musikern aufgegriffen wurde und resampled wurde, was ist das denn? Ich meine, da hat er ja quasi schon fast so ein Gospel irgendwie draus gemacht, dass er immer sagt, Leute zweifeln an, dass wir das schaffen können, aber ja, wir können das. Und das dann immer wieder, also die Repetition.
Ja, und Change. Change war der andere Schlüssel.
Okay, ich lenke vielleicht so ein bisschen ab. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir jetzt hier noch so in unserer Gedankenordnung noch drin sind.
Wir kommen jetzt eigentlich zur Versprachlichung. Wir haben ja jetzt auch schon verschiedene Punkte angesprochen.
Ja, wie würdest du das zusammenfassen? Also was macht diese Versprachlichung?
Da gibt es halt verschiedene Mittel, die angewendet werden. Und das hängt eben davon ab, was man sagen will, wie man sich selber auch darstellen will. Das ist natürlich auch wichtig. Also wir hatten das ja auch immer, wenn z.B. Zirke spricht, das ist kein besonders guter Redner, aber bei Zirke ist es halt immer so, dass er versucht, also der BKA-Chef, irgendwelche Dinge abzubildern. Also nach dem Motto, es ist alles gar nicht so schlimm. Und das merkt man, also immer wenn er redet, gibt es so Untertreibungen, Littotes nennt man das auf Griechisch, oder auch Euphemismen, also dass etwas gut dargestellt wird, was vielleicht gar nicht so gut ist. Also bis hin zu solchen, also irgendwie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Vorrat ist ja eigentlich was Positives. Und es gibt halt andere, die sich immer anders darstellen wollen. Also bei Ursula von der Leyen, das ist auch ein immer wiederkehrendes Muster bei ihr. Sie inszeniert sich halt immer gerne als Powerfrau. Das heißt, es wird immer sehr viel übertrieben. Also hyperben Übertreibungen sind ganz typisch für sie. Also wenn sie dann sagt, wenn sie von den Millionen Geschäft spricht, was im Internet gemacht wird und so. Also solche Übertreibungen kommen halt gerne. Aber es hängt so ein bisschen vom Thema ab. Manchmal passt es mit den Übertreibungen halt nicht. Und manchmal passt es halt ganz gut. Also jetzt, was war das? Ja, wenn der Bundespräsident sich verteidigt, dann immer von Privat-Test spricht, Privateste Dinge. Da fragt man sich, wieso ist das immer so mit dem Superlativ? Privateste Dinge werden...
Jetzt noch privater als privater?
Ja, genau. Das ist dann auch ungeschickt an der Stelle, weil es dann nicht mehr geglaubt wird. Wenn er private Dinge gesagt hätte...
Also mit Übertreibungen kann man es schnell übertreiben.
Genau. Also wenn zum Beispiel Guttenberg sagt, Mühevollste Kleinarbeit, dann wäre aber noch mehr Mühe möglich gewesen. Das wird dann schnell zur Karikatur. Da sollte man immer aufpassen. Gerade das Mittel der Hyperbe so wenig wie möglich einsetzen. Gut, wie gesagt, es hängt davon ab. Nationalsozialismus, da war immer alles ganz hyperbolisch. Wildfanatisch, riesengroß, tausendjährig, totaler Krieg. Das ist aber nicht zeitgemäß. Das wirkt manchmal lächerlich.
Gut, aber ich meine, wenn ich jetzt... Ich plan jetzt eine, was weiß ich, bin jetzt noch nicht so häufig zu Kino-Speeches eingeladen worden. Das wäre jetzt mal hier ein schönes Template. Dann weiß ich dann etwa, worüber ich reden will. Dann hat man quasi eine sprachliche, inhaltliche Ausgangslage geschaffen. Meine Argumente sortiert und da Dramatik reingebracht. Die Argumente angeordnet, dass sie auch ordentlich knallen. Dann haben wir auch schon für den Abgang schon mein Tweet-Template bereitgelegt, was dann alle retweeten dürfen. Kann eigentlich nicht mehr viel passieren. Dann muss ich das aber ja in Worte fassen. Jetzt hast du ja gesagt, ok, bestimmte Dinge sollte man vielleicht sogar die Finger von halten. Kommt immer drauf an, was man beabsichtigt. Ein Euphemismus kann ja dann, wenn ich das Schlimme vorhabe, dann auch hilfreich sein. Aber was funktioniert denn? Das klingt aber jetzt so ein bisschen wie die Vorlage für kommende Diktatoren. Man kann ja auch das Gute im Schilde führen, wenn man jetzt so wie eine Rede hält. Wie versprachliche ich denn jetzt? Ich würde es halt einfach intuitiv machen.
Aber es gibt natürlich schon ein paar Sachen, die du beachten solltest. Also zum Beispiel wäre es ganz gut, vor allen Dingen, wenn du was Abstraktes zum Ausdruck bringen willst bei Keynotes, geht es ja auch oft um abstrakte Dinge. Wenn du eine griffige Metapher...
Die Zukunft des Radios.
Ja, wenn du eine eingängige Metapher hast, also irgendein Bild, das gut passt. Also wenn es zum Beispiel, also als Beispiel mal die Sache mit der Transparenz, also viele reden über Transparenz, aber das ist ja so ein abstrakter Begriff. Und da ist es doch ganz schön, wenn man zum Beispiel sagt, das lese an der Abgeordnetenhaus. Das ist eine Metapher, aber eine, die man sofort begreift. Aber noch eine Gegenüberstellung machen, nicht der gläserne Bürger, sondern das lese an der Abgeordnetenhaus wollen wir.
Der maschinenlesbare Staat.
Genau, das hatten wir auch schon. Daher kommt ja dieser Gedanke auch mit dem gläsernen Abgeordnetenhaus. Das kommt natürlich genau von der Debatte über die Volkszählung und dem maschinenlesbaren Personalausweis. Anfang der 80er, als man gesagt hat, wir wollen keinen maschinenlesbaren Personalausweis, wir wollen einen maschinenlesbaren Staat. Heute passt das nicht mehr.
Ich finde, die Zeit ist ja gerade gekommen.
Ja, aber wenn man in Nördkreisen sagt, der maschinenlesbare Staat, dann mag das noch gehen, weil man sich vielleicht noch dunkler in die Debatte erinnert. Aber sonst ist maschinenlesbar nicht mehr so ein gängiger Begriff. Also da ist es glaube ich besser.
Aber gerade heute erfüllt sich doch dieser Begriff überhaupt erst.
Ja, der erfüllt sich heute erst, aber man sagt nicht mehr maschinenlesbar.
Sondern?
Ich weiß es nicht. Man spricht von biometrischen Ausweistokumenten und so. Das ist ja noch eine Stufe weiter. Aber der biometrische Staat ist jetzt nicht so passend. Der gläserne Bürger, das ist noch ein...
Auf jeden Fall Metaphern finden ist immer eine schöne Sache.
Und wie gesagt, der gläserne Staat, das ist dann vielleicht auch ganz gut.
Aber wie kann man das üben? Sind wir jetzt nicht an so einem Punkt angekommen, wo sich jetzt wirklich die Spräu vom Weizen trennt und es eigentlich wirklich die geistige Fähigkeit sich des Redners einfach zeigt? Und wenn man da nicht auf gute Ideen kommt, dann hilft einem auch die beste Anleitung nicht? Oder hat die Rhetorik da quasi auch Hilfsmittel, mit dem man sich diesen Metaphern nähern kann oder andere Elemente da noch einbringen kann? Oder ist an der Stelle nicht einfach...
Na ja, also Metaphern sind ja meistens auch zu Gruppen zusammenfassbar. Da kann man ja gucken, was passt jetzt in mein Thema? Ist das ein Thema, wo ich irgendwas Geografisches bringen kann? Wo ich irgendwas vielleicht ein Bild bringen kann, was vielleicht mit dem Krieg zusammenhängt? Passt natürlich nicht immer. Da muss man eben sehen, was man macht. Und man sollte wirklich das Richtige machen. Also keine Kriegsmetaphern, wenn es nicht passt.
Aber grundsätzlich gilt eigentlich die Ansage, hast du einen schwer darstellbaren Sachverhalt? Hast du etwas, was besonders abstrakt ist oder von der Komplexität der dahinterliegenden Argumente einfach schwer zu summieren ist? Dann sollte man sich auf die Suche machen nach einem Bild. Sollte man versuchen, dieses Konstrukt, was man im Kopf hat, quasi mit Aquarellfarben sich auszumalen und dann mal zu gucken, wo es da Ähnlichkeiten gibt, die andere Leute nachvollziehen können.
Genau. Also ich hab hier so einen Text zum Beispiel, da geht es um neuronale Netze und das Gehirn. War in der Zeit schon ein bisschen älter. Und da wird eben auch sehr viel mit Metaphern gearbeitet, weil man das halt schlecht darstellen kann. Gerade in so einem schriftlichen Text, da heißt es dann gleich auf der Anfang, auf der Recherche nach dem, was Leib und Geist im Innersten zusammenhält, ist die Wissenschaft nicht zu den letzten, sondern zu den kleinsten Dingen vorgestoßen. Das setzt sich dann fort, dieses Vorstoßen. Da kommt nochmal Bastion und Kreuzzug, das ist dann so ein bisschen kämpferisch. Aber auch dann Leib und Geist im Innersten zusammenhält, das ist angelehnt an Goethe, Zitat. Das mit der Recherche ist auch etwas seltsam, vielleicht auch angelehnt an Zitat. Und dann geht es halt weiter. Ihre jüngste Bastion, da haben wir wieder diese Kriegsmetapher, sind die neuronalen Netze des Gehirns. Die letzten weißen Flecken in der langen Kolonialgeschichte der physiologischen Landnahme. Geografie, weiße Flecken, Landnahme, Kolonialgeschichte. Also das passt dann zusammen. Und dann geht es weiter. Du wirst von den seelischen Provinzen gesprochen. Die Beschriftung des Hirns als eine Art Globus steht da. Bleibt weiter in dem... Und dann kommt sogar ganz am Ende die Geografie der Seele. Und dann kommt auch das Wort Ansiedeln. Ja, und dann sieht man, das wird nicht nur eine Metapher genommen, sondern das Ganze.
Man wählt sich sozusagen eine Kategorie von Metaphern, was einerseits den Vorteil hat, dass die Leute in dieser Gedankenwelt dann schon eingenordet sind. Und dass man aber auch selber quasi so ein Fundus sich eröffnet, aus dem man sich dann vielleicht auch einfacher bedienen kann, was einfach auch den Zusammenbau besser macht. Sofern man von vornherein schon mal einen Kontext gewählt hat, der angemessen ist, sonst rasselt man mit jedem weiteren Beispiel dann noch tiefer.
Genau, wenn es völlig falsch ist, ist es natürlich schlecht. Aber wenn man sich da...
Ja, Hitler-Vergleich, ne? Gott, Winslaw. Das ist... Verstehe. Was ist mit Humor? Ich hab gemerkt, dass Humor, abgesehen davon, dass man, wie du ja schon gesagt hast, mit einem Witz erstmal alle ein bisschen auflockert. Alle sitzen da steif, wissen nicht so richtig, was Sache ist. Wenn man erstmal reinkommt und einen guten Spruch auf den Tisch legt. Witz machen ist jetzt auch nicht jedermanns Sache. Es gibt Leute, denen liegt es irgendwie so auf der Zunge. Aber zumindest überhaupt mal durchscheinen zu lassen, dass man sich unter der Situation auch nicht zu ernst nimmt. Was ich auch immer finde, ist, auf keinen Fall auch so lächerlich machen, dass man das Gefühl hat, man nimmt die Situation nicht ernst. Es ist auch so eine schwer zu finden Abgleich, wie weit man jetzt gehen kann. Aber trotzdem, Humor macht es einfach.
Es gibt nur ein Mittel, was ein bisschen mit der Metapher zusammenhängt und was auch den Humor bringt, das ist die Ironie. Dass man etwas meint, aber anders sagt. Aber der Hörer versteht, dass es anders gemeint ist. Das ist sehr wirkungsvoll. Weil der Hörer dann eben auch mitdenken muss und dann auch so einen Aha-Effekt hat, weil er was merkt.
Wie viele Leute verstehen denn Ironie?
Das geht gut. Also wenn die Ironie entsprechend ist. Also siehe wieder Mark Antonius mit dem Brutus, der ein ehrenhafter Mann ist. Beim ersten Mal weiß man nicht so genau, wie meint das denn? Vielleicht meint das ja so. Aber indem man das immer wiederholt, steigert sich das. Und am Ende glaubt niemand mehr, dass Brutus ein ehrenhafter Mann ist. Und in Shakespeare's Theaterstück gehen die ja dann auch auf die Zesamörder los. Wo es ja auch in der Geschichte so viel ist verbirgt, dass die Rede zumindest so gut war, dass er das Volk gegen die Zesamörder aufstacheln konnte, die ja eigentlich als Retter der Republik gefeiert werden wollten. Das ist dann schief gegangen. Und wie er das gemacht hat, weiß man nicht. Also bei Shakespeare ist es dann genau diese Ironie, dass er immer als ehrenhaft dargestellt wird. Aber wenn dann die blutige Toga hochgehalten wird und so, dann verschwindet die Ehrenhaftigkeit. Und dann ist es plötzlich nicht mehr gemeint, obwohl es immer noch gesagt wird. Oder ein anderes Beispiel. Ich habe zum Beispiel in meinem Vortrag an der Stelle, wo ich dieses Beispiel gebracht habe, dass ein Politiker, der nicht näher genannt wurde, sich mit Maschmeyer trifft. Ich habe dann gesagt, das tun ja viele Politiker. Und außerdem würde ich die Identität nicht offenlegen aus Respekt vor dem Amt. Da wurde sofort gelacht. Also irgendwie...
Zu Recht irgendwie auch weggelegt.
Ich habe nichts, wirklich nichts gesagt an der Stelle. Aber wenn du sagst, ich will verstehen, das haben irgendwie alle verstanden an der Stelle.
Also Ironie ganz oben auf der Liste.
Ja, naja gut, wenn man es übertreibt und nur noch Ironie bringt, ist es irgendwann tot.
Aber kann man auf jeden Fall machen. Wenn man Humor hat. Wenn man humorlos ist?
Ja, dann wird es schwierig. Humorlose Leute sollten besser schweigen. Generell. Ich meine, das ist doch klar. Also ich kann mich erinnern aus meiner Zeit, als ich hier in Berlin an der Uni war, da gab es einen Kollegen, der galt irgendwie als Intrigant. Na ja, also dann wollte man mit dem eigentlich nicht viel zu tun haben. Wollte ich eigentlich auch nicht. Aber ich bin das ein oder andere Mal mit ihm essen gegangen. Und dann sagte die Sekretärin in der Abteilung, warum ich denn mit ihm schon wieder essen ginge. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja gut, der mag ja charakterlich seltsam sein, also vielleicht so eine Art Soziopath, aber er ist sehr geistreich. Und ich will mich ja nicht langweilen beim Essen. Das ist doch ganz nett. Und das hat sie dann eingesehen. Also ich denke, das ist wichtig, dass die Menschen geistreich sind. Natürlich sollten sie auch charakterlich gut sein, klar.
Aber wenn man intrigant ist, dann wenigstens mit Humor.
Also ich denke, das ist ganz wichtig. Also wenn man gute Reden halten will, sollte auch immer etwas Humor dabei sein. Man muss es nicht übertreiben, hängt ja auch vom Thema ab. Also eine Totenrede jetzt mit Witzen wäre vielleicht nicht immer so gut. Aber man sollte eben auch in schwierigen Situationen auch mal was, also dezenten Humor zeigen.
Was man ja auch immer wieder von schlechten Rednern dann so sagt, oder wenn man eine schlechte Rede, oder ein Merkmal von was ich so wahrnehme, ist, dass man dann auch sagt, das war aber jetzt monoton gesprochen. Nicht selten meint man damit ja auch tatsächlich die Tonlage, in dem das Ganze wiedergegeben wird. Also dass man den Vortrag dann doch in einem sehr, fast ohne Melodie vorträgt. Und das könnte man ja sich vielleicht auch mal anschauen. Und wie wichtig ist Melodie? Also muss man, sollte man schon singen.
Deshalb sagte ich ja schon vorhin, man muss halt dieses mit den Atemübungen hinbekommen, mal so richtig in einem Schwung. Ein Satz sagt auch mit einer gewissen Melodie, ganz klar. Es geht nicht einfach, dass man das monoton abliest.
Hilft es, in Chor zu gehen oder so?
Ja, hilft vielleicht auch.
Gesangsunterricht?
Ja, Gesangsunterricht könnte helfen. Man kann auch Stimmunterricht machen, sonst was alles. Also da gibt es schon Möglichkeiten. Wichtig ist halt, dass man so einen Spannungsbogen hat, und der muss auch in der Intimation drin sein. Deshalb ganz schlecht ist es, sich zu Hause hinzusetzen, einen Text auszuarbeiten, schriftlich, eventuell mit Schachtel setzen und so, die man nie vortragen kann, und das dann abzulesen. Das geht nicht gut.
Das Schreiben scheint mir auch deshalb ein Problem zu sein, weil, also es ist ja auch sehr verbreitet, Holger hat das Thema auch mal eingebracht, so dieses, das Schreiben fürs Lesen und das Schreiben fürs Reden ist was anderes. Also die Sätze, die man auf Papierband, die ja einfach auch anders aufgenommen werden, nämlich eben mit dem Auge und nicht mit dem Ohr, haben einen anderen Charakter. Da sieht man das Komma, da hat man den Gedankenstrich, da sind so diese Elemente mit drin und das Ganze schafft dann auch so die Basis eben für längere, komplexere Sätze. Aber das Ohr scheint da nicht in demselben Maße belastbar zu sein.
Genau, das ist ganz klar. Und da gibt es auch Fehler, die Leute machen. Also wenn sie fürs Sprechen schreiben, auch übrigens gerade bei Journalisten, im Radio hört man das manchmal, dass sie dann Inversionskonstruktionen verwenden, statt der leichter zu verstehenen Konstruktionen mit einer Konjunktion.
Was meinst du damit?
Also als Beispiel, ich kann ja im Deutschen sagen, ja, ist so ein schönes Beispiel, wenn...
Also was ist denn eine Inversion?
Ja, also ich kann sagen, wenn es regnet, ist die Straße nass. Ich kann aber auch sagen, regnet es, ist die Straße nass. Inversion ist regnet, es ist die Straße nass. Und das lässt sich sehr viel schlechter verstehen, als wenn ich das Wenn benutze. Die Inversion ist vor allen Dingen schriftsprachlich sehr verbreitet. Und jetzt gibt es dann Leute, die schreiben so und tragen das dann eben auch mündlich so vor. Und das ist immer... Das kann auf die Dauer ermüdend werden, wenn das immer wieder kommt. Das Gegenteil ist zum Beispiel, dass man... Oder eine andere solche Konstruktion, also bei Wenn hat man es, das geht aber das Gleiche auch mit Kausalsätzen. Also statt irgendeines Weil oder Denn-Satzes, sage ich auch, kann ich das umdrehen und sagen... Also ich darf sagen, weil er das schon gesagt hat, hat er das doch gesagt. Und das ist auch schlecht zu pasen, wenn man es hört.
Ja, es gibt ja einen interessanten Bruch, gerade so hier in unseren Audio-Welten, das Hörbuch. Das ist ja auch sehr populär, weil es einem quasi das Lesen einfacher macht. Ich persönlich habe so ein bisschen meine Schwierigkeiten damit. Ich meine, ich habe auch schon Schwierigkeiten mit dem Lesen. Also ich bin nicht so ein Buchwurm, ich muss mich anstrengen, wenn ich ein Buch lange durchhalten will. Ich weiß gar nicht, was das ausmacht, aber ich habe da irgendwie eine Konzentrationsschwäche. Also das muss mich extrem packen und fesseln. Und es muss mir auch vorher irgendwie schon klar sein, dass das will ich jetzt auch in mich aufnehmen. Das interessiert mich so sehr. Es gibt so Leute, die können so Bücher einfach so weglesen. Und wissen dann am Ende so, dass ihnen das gefallen hat oder auch nicht. Das Hörbuch hat dann für mich eben die doppelte Belastung, dass eben ja eigentlich nur das, was da zum Lesen gedacht war, gesprochen wird. Und von daher für mich irgendwie noch belastender ist. Dann gibt es wiederum das Hörspiel, das ja eigentlich bewusst darauf hingeschrieben wird, um gehört zu werden. Hence the name. Die dann aber auch in so einem, also das ist wirklich so ein bisschen meine persönliche Sichtweise an der Stelle, aber vielleicht hast du ja auch einen Kommentar dazu, was dann wiederum so Theater spielt, finde ich. Also so ein Hörspiel. Also mir kommt das immer so vor, als säße ich dann im Theater, weil dann eben so gedunsen gesprochen wird.
Ja, das ist dann auch Schwisslichkeit eigentlich. Das ist nicht Mündlichkeit.
Also mir geht das auch im Theater so, dass ich immer das Gefühl habe, so redet doch keiner. Was gibt ihr da so für Laute von euch? Was ist das für ein Reden? Das ist doch einfach ineffizient.
Das geht aber meistens nicht anders. Wenn die da so reden würden, wie man wirklich redet, dann versteht man es nicht mehr. Denn da ist ja eine besondere Kommunikationssituation. Auf der Bühne reden zwei Leute miteinander, aber eigentlich soll der Zuschauer verstehen, was da vor sich geht. Das heißt also, die müssen ganz anders reden, als man normalerweise miteinander redet. Denn wenn Leute normalerweise miteinander reden, dann wissen sie schon den Kontext und kennen sie schon. Und dann wird nur noch ein Minimum gesagt.
Aber wir reden doch jetzt auch miteinander, damit Leute zu hören. Wir fangen jetzt auch nicht an, in Theatersprache zu reden.
Stimmt schon, da hast du recht. Aber hier ist es ja nochmal, wir bauen ja hier nicht irgendeine Situation zwischen uns auf, die wir vermitteln müssen.
Es ist nicht so orchestriert, es ergibt sich. Zumindest tun wir so.
Es kommt wirklich auch daher, dass die Leute das eben vorher schriftlich planen und dann eben das eigentlich geschriebene Sprache ist.
Aber wie du ja schon verraten hast, so ganz ungeplant sind wir nicht. Ich versuche immer ungeplant zu sein. Also zwei, drei Notizen sind schon da. Jetzt könnte ich zum Beispiel so, Aber Maha, muss man denn nicht auch noch am Ende einen Höhepunkt bieten?
Ja gut, das klingt natürlich dann künstlich.
Gut, dass du das sagst, Tim. Das bringt mich doch gleich zum nächsten Punkt.
Ja, das ist dann ein Studium. Genau, das gibt es ja auch.
Ja, dieses ein Studium. Dann gibt es nämlich auch noch so diese Kandidaten. Ich hatte auch noch einen Freund von mir, ich nenne jetzt mal keine Namen. Die sind irgendwie mehr so Schreiberlinge. Schreiber und Leserlinge. Und wenn die dann gebeten werden, irgendwie einen Vortrag zu halten, dann haben die dann einfach hier Manuskript und dann können die nicht anders. Die müssen es vorlesen. Da gibt es einfach keine Qualität, das zu machen. Und das ist ja auch so ein Übel, was sehr verbreitet ist. Dass Leute einfach da so hinkommen und ernsthaft der Meinung sind, wenn sie jetzt da ihren Text vorlesen, im schlimmsten Fall dann auch noch irgendeinen wissenschaftlichen, soziologischen, verkopften Text, dann wird es einfach super langweilig. Also das ist dann einfach, da möchte ich dann auch, da habe ich dann auch schon ein bisschen so Gewaltfantasien manchmal.
Also abgelesene Sachen, das ist wirklich ganz schrecklich.
Oder abgelesene Slides.
Oder noch besser, der Höhepunkt, das ist jetzt vor allen Dingen, will da jetzt auch nicht irgendwelche Personengruppen, Brandmarken, aber es gibt da solche, die behalten einen Text vor, den sie vor, also ihren gesamten Vortrag, der ist aufgeschrieben, die lesen den nur ab, in rasender Geschwindigkeit und zeigen dazu Slides, die auch voll mit Text sind, aber die anderen Texte enthalten, als der der vorgelesen wäre. Und das versuch mal zu pasen.
Das ist echt Content-Terror.
Ja, und das muss dann eben, also das muss wirklich abgestimmt sein. Also wer das gut kann, seine Slides auf das gesprochene Wort abzustimmen, ist halt lässig in seinen Vorträgen. Das wirkt zwar auf die Dauer auch, dann irgendwann, also ich kann es jetzt nicht mehr sehen, ich finde das auch ein bisschen anscheinend, weil es sehr, sehr plakativ ist. Aber am Anfang fand ich, als ich den ersten lässigen Vortrag gehört habe, fand ich das gelungen.
Ja, aber weißt du was für ein Problem ich damit habe? Da fehlt mir dann so ein anderes Element. Da fehlt mir manchmal einfach so die Pause. Da fehlt mir einfach und vor allem auch die Pause gar nicht so sehr nach dem Motto, ich meine man ist ja da um zu reden. Man soll ja die Zeit auch nutzen. Also von daher ist das ja vollkommen in Ordnung, dass man da eben in dem Fall der Einzige ist, der spricht. Nur eine Pause, wie sie bei uns einfach dadurch entsteht, dass wir dann auch mal zwischendurch über was nachdenken müssen, kann man dann in Vorträgen finde ich auch so einbauen, einerseits natürlich um so ein bisschen Drama zu erzeugen, andererseits aber auch um einfach den Leuten auch mal die Gelegenheit zu geben, zu verarbeiten. Also dass man auch gar nicht nur so sehr in der Vermittlung spricht, sondern dass man auch mal Raum schafft, um nachdenken zu können. Vielleicht auch einfach mal so Filmchen macht sich manchmal ganz gut oder ein Bild angucken oder so. Jetzt kommen wir so ein bisschen über das Rhetorische hinaus und gehen schon mehr so über, wie sollte ein Vortrag sein. Aber das ist das, was mir bei so einem Ansatz wie diesen Vorträgen von Lässig einfach fehlt. Weil das einfach auch so ein Argumentestacato ist, wo ich dann so am Schluss dann so sitze und denke mir so, ok, jetzt habe ich das Gefühl, ich bin von so einem Rhetorik-Maschinengewehr befeuert worden. Und da gehe ich dann nicht so richtig mit. Das ist mir einfach dann auch schon wieder zu unnatürlich.
Ja, das stimmt.
Aber vielleicht bin ich auch einfach nur so ein Naturalist.
Naja, es ist einfach so, dass Lässiges dann zu weit treibt. Also im Grunde ist das schon vom Ansatz her nicht schlecht, dass man halt so Folien hat, auf denen wenig steht, die aber in engem Zusammenhang zu dem stehen, was man sagt. Aber es sollte halt nicht zu so einem Stacato werden. Also da wäre weniger dann mehr.
Das ist ja auch so ein Stil, der vor ein paar Jahren so aufkam. Dieses nur noch ein einziges Wort auf dem Slide und dieses vollsynchronisierte Ding und so. Aber ich habe manchmal ehrlich gesagt das Gefühl, auch da herrscht die Selbstverliebtheit. Dass man es geil findet, wie toll man sich da jetzt so präsentiert. Und manche gehen dann irgendwie dem auch auf den Leim oder finden es vielleicht auch wirklich mal toll. Aber am Ende leidet die Botschaft.
Naja, das ist interessant eigentlich. Im Grunde, wenn du jetzt mal Steve Jobs anguckst bei seinen Präsentationen, da ist auch eine enge Interaktion zwischen Slides und seinem Vortrag. Aber möglicherweise ist das geschau- spielert, ich weiß es nicht genau. Es wirkt immer so ein bisschen unbeholfen.
Was genau wirkt unbeholfen?
Na die Interaktion, dann hat er da seinen Knopf, dann muss er sich umdrehen und so. Das ist nicht wirklich unbeholfen, aber da sind so, es ist halt nicht so ein Staccato. Genau. Das wirkt dann einfach irgendwie so, als müsste es so sein.
Genau, es unterstützt das, was gesagt wurde. Also das, was man sich jetzt, weil es ist ja auch das Problem, wenn man zum Beispiel, manche Sachen kann man gut sagen, aber andere Dinge wiederum bleiben vom Gesagten schlecht hängen, vor allem Zahlen. Wenn ich jetzt sage, ja, wir haben uns das mal angeschaut, und dann war 97% so, ja, und in 3 von 100 Fällen, und übrigens gab es 27 Millionen Fälle, wo dann irgendwie nur 432.000 sind. Und dann hast du diesen Satz gehört, und dann weißt du schon nicht mehr, wo jetzt noch eine Null mehr oder weniger dranhing, was jetzt eine Milliarde, eine Million, eine Billiarde, Billiarde, Billion war. Alles verzerrt sich und ist nicht da. Wenn aber in dem Moment dann quasi hinten diese Essenz, diese Zahlen dann visuell sind, wo wir extrem drauf trainiert sind, wenn die dann auch richtig angeordnet sind und die Zahlen auch zueinander im Kontext stehen und eine große Zahl auch groß ist, viele Nullen ausgeschrieben sind, man eben dieses Größenverhältnis untereinander auch sofort wahrnehmen kann, dann ist es eben eine Unterstützung. So empfinde ich das zumindest.
Ja, doch, das ist auf jeden Fall richtig. Da passt es dann auch mit den Slides. Genau, die sollten dann wirklich unterstützend wirken.
Naja, also wir sind ja eigentlich immer noch so ein bisschen hier in unserem Kanon der Fünf.
Wir sind eigentlich immer noch bei der Versprachlichung. Und da hatten wir über Ironie, Metaphern, Euphemismen, die Tod ist hyperbel gesprochen.
Und jetzt demonstrieren wir gerade eine weitere Qualität, dass die Zusammenfassung an der Stelle vielleicht auch hilfreich ist. Die hast du aber nicht auf der Liste.
Ich wollte jetzt noch was zur Anordnung sagen. Wir hatten zwar schon das Gedankenordnen auf der Makro-Ebene, aber auf der Mikro-Ebene kann man Dinge auch geschickt anordnen. Da ist die Frage, wie ist das mit der Reihenfolge von einzelnen Wörtern oder Satzteilen? Da gibt es zwei Möglichkeiten, dass man Sachen klimatisch anordnet, wie man sagt. Also Klimax, das ist eigentlich Leiter auf Griechisch. Eine dreistufige Leiter, eine Steigerung. Oder Antiklimax, das Gegenteil, dass es dann schwächer wird. Also berühmte Beispiele, Vini vidi vici, oder Viki, lateinisch sagt Caesar, ich kam, sah, segte. Drei Sachen, die fangen auch gleich noch mit dem gleichen Buchstaben an. Oder ganz berühmt, da ist Rumpelstilzien, der berühmte Spruch, heute backe ich, morgen braue ich, übermorgen hole ich der Königin ihr Kind. Genau, das sind drei Sachen hintereinander, wobei das letzte auch am längsten ist. Und diese Dreiergruppen sind ganz typisch, da gibt es auch einen Namen dafür, schon seit den Griechen, also das Trikolon, dass man drei Sachen aneinander ordnet und dann möglicherweise eine Steigerung da drin hat oder eine Abschwächung, je nachdem. Steigerung ist gut, wenn man sowieso mehr Hyperbeln hat und Schwächung ist besser, wenn man etwas zurücknehmen will oder Euphemismen oder Litotis verwenden will.
Oder was?
Litotis, eine Abschwächung, eine Untertreibung. Ja, gibt's auch schöne Beispiele. Ich hatte ja schon diese Literarischen genannt. Es gibt noch eine Rede von Willy Brandt, die wir leider bei YouTube nicht gefunden haben. Aber es gibt den Text, 17. Juni 1973. Da sagt er, die Geschichte sehen, die Realitäten erkennen, die Chancen der Zukunft nicht verspielen. Nur so können wir den Menschen unseres Volkes dienen. Hüben und üben, nur so können wir bestehen. Wenn man sich das genauer anschaut, das ist erst die Dreiergruppe. Die Geschichte sehen, die Realitäten erkennen, die Chancen der Zukunft nicht verspielen. Das ist chronologisch angeordnet. Die Geschichte, Realität ist jetzt, Zukunft ist danach. Das ist der erste Teil. Und dann kommt der zweite Teil. Der hat auch wieder eine Dreierkonstellation. Da heißt es zuerst, nur so können wir den Menschen unseres Volkes dienen. Dann kommt dieser Einschub, das ist das zweite. Hüben und Rüben, weil es da ja um die DDR ging. Und dann der Schluss, nur so können wir bestehen. Das ist dann das Ganze auf einer höheren Ebene, einer moralischen Ebene. Nur so können wir bestehen. Also auch genau auf der Mikroebene eingeteilt. Wir haben also erstmal diesen Durchgang von der Geschichte in die Zukunft, wobei natürlich auch eine Steigerung da drin ist. Zukunft ist natürlich das, was am weitesten geht. Und ja, wir haben dieses Sehen, Erkennen und dann nicht Verspielen. Also tatsächlich auch in den Verben noch Steigerung. Und dann einmal das Dienen. Die Menschen in unserem Volk sind Dienen. Und dann letztlich das Bestehen auch wieder die Zukunft. Und eben dieser moralische Anspruch, der dahinter steckt.
Wie ist jetzt besonders bekannt die Rede eigentlich?
Nö, aber das ist halt so ein Beispiel, wo man sehen kann, wie auf der Mikroebene genau überlegt wurde, was zu sagen ist.
Weißt du, ob er die Rede selber geschrieben hat?
Na, das weiß man nie. Wenn jemand schon Bundeskanzler ist, hat er natürlich Leute, die ihm zuarbeiten.
Gibt es denn irgendwie... Gibt es nicht so Leute, die auch, hier kocht der Chef noch selbst, mäßig unterwegs und auch dafür bekannt waren?
Also, Willy Brandt gehört sicherlich zu denen, die da auch selber Hand angelegt haben. Also selbst wenn er jemanden hatte, der ihm zuarbeitete, ist er da noch drüber gegangen. Also das Reden halten war, dafür war er ja sehr bekannt, das heißt also er musste das auch, also ich denke er hat selber nochmal, ist da nochmal drüber gegangen.
Wenn man sich so alte Reden, also wenn man sich so altes Bundestags-Fernsehen anguckt, also die alten Reden, hier so gehäuft auftauchen, gibt es da eigentlich irgendeine zentrale Quelle? Es landet einfach alles so auf YouTube irgendwie.
Ja, das müsste es mal geben, also der Bundestag müsste daran mal arbeiten. Jetzt wird ja alles registriert, jetzt gibt es ja auch ein Archiv, aber die älteren Sachen müssten wieder zusammengestellt werden.
Ja, das wäre sehr interessant, vor allem natürlich mit so einer Verschlagwortung. Aber davon unabhängig, es beschleicht einen so ein Gefühl, ich sag nicht, das ist so, dass so der sprachliche Umgang auch anders gewesen ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob da noch man das jetzt mit alte Schule bezeichnen kann oder ob das einfach nur so geboren war aus anderen Höflichkeitsrealitäten, die da noch gefahren wurden, andere Protokolle, die da quasi in Kraft waren, die heutzutage nicht mehr so gängig sind. Heißt auch nicht, dass ich jetzt modernerer Redenführung nie habe etwas abgewinnen können. Trotzdem, weiß nicht, wie nimmst du das wahr? Hat sich da was getan? Ändert sich die Redekultur? Ist es irgendwie schlechter geworden? Oder ist es irgendwie nur anders?
Ja, naja, also ich glaube schon, dass man da so eine Entwicklung sehen kann. Also ich glaube schon, dass das Reden eine wichtige Technik ist, also auch immer noch, aber dass es da tatsächlich so eine gewisse Schule gibt, wo das sehr formell war, wo es auch drauf ankam, dass sich Leute eben auch durchsetzen, dadurch, dass sie gut reden können. Das geht so bis in die 70er Jahre oder 80er Jahre vielleicht, und dann gibt es so einen Umschwung, dass mehr so, also das merkt man auch ganz deutlich an der Art der Metaphorik, die so kommt. Da gibt es dann mehr so Fußballmetaphern und so, oder da geht es irgendwie darum, ja es ist vielleicht so eine Art Richtung Populismus, vielleicht noch kein richtiger Populismus, aber es wird dann immer gezeigt, ja ich bin einer von euch, das findet ihr letztlich den Gipfel jetzt bei Wolf, der sagt ja, was man so tut als Bundeskanzler, als Bundespräsident, als sei jeder Bundespräsident.
Sie wissen das doch, wie das ist.
Ja, also das ist dieses, ja Leute, die sich gemein machen, ich bin einer von euch, sagen, das ist glaube ich sehr, sehr wichtig geworden. Merkt man auch in anderen Ländern, also bei Berlusconi sehr stark, bei Sarkozy, also die setzen sehr darauf. Also Berlusconi ist so der König der Fußballmetaphern. Alle seine Metaphern kommen irgendwie aus dem Fußball bis hin zu seiner Partei, die heißt Forza Italia, Vorwärts Italien, das ist halt der Schlachtruf der Fans im Fußballspiel, also sozusagen auch ein Gesamtbild. Und jetzt, glaube ich, endet es tatsächlich wieder, weil auch im Internet was Neues da ist, nämlich dass diese Reden alle verfügbar sind. Da kann man sich eigentlich keinen Zufall mehr überlassen. Also kann man sich nicht mehr dem Zufall überlassen, sondern da muss wirklich alles stimmen. Deshalb glaube ich ja auch, dass jetzt gerade in der Auseinandersetzung um Christian Wulf er da einen Fehler gemacht hat, weil er das Internet verkannt hat.
Und auch Herr von und zu über und unter Gutenberg.
Ja, sowieso. Dass der Internet-Spezialist jetzt geworden ist bei der EU, passt nun gar nicht. Also der hat das Internet gar nicht verstanden. Das merkt man ja sehr schön bei seiner ersten Pressekonferenz. Da fängt er ja an und fängt dann noch mal an.
Kann ich das noch mal machen?
Ja, das ist natürlich auch bei YouTube. Da muss man doch wissen, dass das heute nicht mehr geht.
Das ist auch eine schöne Summary für sein ganzes Wirken bisher.
Kann ich noch mal anfangen? Das ist jetzt eben anders. Und jetzt kommt es da sehr viel mehr drauf an. Weil eben alles da ist. Man kann auch nachher nicht mehr das Protokoll umschreiben, wie der Ull das gemacht hat, weil die Originalaufnahmen da sind. Und deshalb muss man jetzt mehr darauf achten. Deshalb wäre es für den Wulff besser gewesen, wieder eine Erklärung abzugeben vor der Bundespressekonferenz und anschließend Questions and Answers. Denn dann hätten alle Leute das Transkript seiner Erklärung verbreitet. Das wäre auch in Ausschnitten gefilmt worden. Und die Questions und Answers wären so ein bisschen untergegangen. Es sei denn, da wäre wirklich ein großer Klopfer gewesen. Und wahrscheinlich hat er es nicht gemacht, weil er Angst vor dem großen Klopfer hatte. Wahrscheinlich ist da noch was zu finden. Und deshalb, naja, hat er es wahrscheinlich... Also es ist die einzige Erklärung, denn sonst ist es dumm. Diese Sache mit dem Interview war einfach ganz unpassend. Weil wir auch gesehen haben, Sperrfristen und so, das ist in der Zeitlade des Netzes nicht mehr möglich. Denn der Text, den Text hätte man auch um 18 Uhr online stellen können. Denn bevor die Rede gehalten wurde, war ja durch Crowdsourcing der Text schon...
Ja, wir müssen jetzt dazu sagen, wir sind jetzt gerade ganz tagesaktuell verspult. Das war jetzt zum Zeitpunkt dieser Aufnahme gestern. Keine Ahnung, welche Bedeutung dieser Tag in der Zukunft noch hat. Ob die Sache jetzt einfach wieder unter dem Teppich verschwindet oder ob wir uns jetzt hier gerade nur in Teil 2 eines mehrteiligen Dramas befinden.
Das lässt sich jetzt nicht so richtig sagen. Das wird ja bald online gehen, denke ich mal. Du brauchst ja nicht so lange wie ich für die Veröffentlichung von Podcasts. Von daher wird das noch einigermaßen aktuell sein. Aber kann sein, wenn der online geht, gibt es vielleicht schon Teil 3 des Dramas. Also fünf Akte hat ja ein gutes Drama.
Dann wird er aber der Fünf.
Ja, nee, das ist irgendwie ganz wichtig. Das haben die damals eben schon gemerkt, dass diese Fünfteiligkeit irgendwie sehr gut geeignet ist.
Und die Dreier.
Und die Dreier, ja.
Drei und Fünf. Ist echt strange. Warum?
Naja, es hängt halt damit zusammen, dass man eben...
Weil man fünf Finger hat?
Ja, nee, also mehr als fünf ist halt schwer...
Ja gut, aber warum?...
macht zu verarbeiten. Weil man sich nicht so viel merken kann. Aber fünf kann man sich halt irgendwie gut merken. Außerdem glaube ich, ist die Asymmetrie wichtig. Denn bei vier hat man immer so zwei und zwei, das paart sich dann irgendwie, dann hat man irgendwie...
Ja, das wird ja eine richtig diskretische Ausgabe, ne? Ich meine klar, in der Fünf ist die Zwei und die Drei, ne? Da hat man so die Zweier- und die Dreiergruppe, die so irgendwie zueinander steht. Aber vielleicht ist es auch einfach die Hand, die an der Stelle irgendwie mitspielt, so dieses Fünf-Dinge, die man abzählen kann, ne? Mal alle unbegradet sein und so. Da steckt irgendwie viel drin in der Fünf und den Fünf-Stern sowieso, aber ich will es hier gar nicht in die Mystik abgleiten.
Man muss da nicht mystisch sein. Also es ist sicherlich so, dass so ein Fünfer-Schema mehr Möglichkeiten bietet. Da kann ich unterschiedlich gruppieren. Da kann ich sagen, erstmal der Anfang, dann habe ich so eine Dreiergruppe, und dann habe ich nochmal ein Ende.
Also die Drei eingeschlossen in die Zwei.
Das ist schon praktisch. Und bei Vier geht das irgendwie nicht. Wie soll ich das machen bei einer Vier? Da kann ich eins und zwei und dann nochmal... Da gibt es keine Mitte, ja.
Ja, die Mitte hatten wir jetzt erreicht. Fällt dir noch was ein zur Versprachlichung?
Ja, zur Versprachlichung. Also wie gesagt, Klimax ist halt wichtig. Dann auch das Gesetz der wachsenden Glieder. Das habe ich glaube ich noch nicht genannt. Dass, wenn man etwas Längeres noch sagen will, das besser am Ende kommt, auch artentechnisch. Wenn ich erst etwas Langes sage und dann etwas Kurzes...
Wie erst im Sinne von über den Zeitraum der kompletten Rede?
Nein, nein, nein, nur in einem, sozusagen in einem Atemzug. Also in einem Absatz oder einen Satz oder sogar in einer Wortgruppe. Wenn ich eine Wortgruppe bringe, ist immer... Also hier nochmal als Beispiel, da kann man sofort erzählen.
Jetzt mach das doch gleich mal.
Also er sagt eben, die Geschichte sehen, die Realitäten erkennen, die Chancen der Zukunft nicht verspielen. Also das lange zum Schluss.
Okay, verstehe.
Wenn ich erst was Langes sage, dann passt das irgendwie nicht.
Okay, verstehe. Also innerhalb eines Satzes.
Bei Merkel ist Merkel nicht so eine besonders gute Rednerin, aber das hat sie eben auch. Wir werden nicht zulassen, dass technisch manches möglich ist. Aber der Staat ist nicht nutzt. Dafür aber die Verbrecher und Täter und Terroristen es nutzen. Also das lange zum Schluss. Da haben wir dann die Dreiergliederung. Verbrecher und Täter und Terroristen. Auch wieder mit einer Steigerung.
Also man merkt schon, dass da Leute am Werk sind, die zumindest sich über die Grundzüge der Rhetorik an der Stelle auch Gedanken machen. Ja, klar. So Redenschreiber werden. Wie wird man denn das eigentlich? Kann man sich dann zu so einem Rhetoriker auch wirklich ausbilden lassen? Oder ist das einfach alles Veranlagung?
Na ja, es gibt natürlich viele Kurse. Die man überall, die parteinahen Stiftungen machen Kurse, damit eben die eigenen Politiker das auch auf die Reihe kriegen. Hab ich ja schon mal dargestellt auf dem Kongress vor drei Jahren. Der Laien-Rhetorik. Da haben wir bei Ursula von der Leyen halt viele solche sehr plakativen Dinge sieht, wo man sieht, das hat sie irgendwie gelernt mit den Feiergruppen und dann kommt das immer und immer wieder. Das ist natürlich auch nicht gut. Es ist schon gut, wenn mal was Ungewöhnliches kommt. Also eine ungewöhnliche Reihenfolge oder so. Aber jetzt nicht einfach, weil man es nicht kann, sondern bei der man sich eben auch was überlegt hat. Und das fehlt dann eben bei so Rhetorikern aus dem Rhetorikkurs. Und dann ist es auch wieder billig. Okay, also das ist schon auch nochmal wichtig, dass irgendwie was kommt, wo man aha sagt. Und das ist natürlich auch etwas, was man nicht unbedingt so lernen kann. Man kann die Schema zwar lernen, aber das Besondere muss man dann irgendwie selbst hinkriegen. Ja, aber wie gesagt, Kurse gibt es überall. Ich hab ja auch sowas schon mal bei der Piratenpartei gemacht. Es war sehr interessant auch, das Ergebnis zu sehen. Ich hab in der ersten Sitzung am Ende noch so ein paar Tipps gegeben, was man vermeiden sollte. Andreas Baum war da nicht da, der war erst in der zweiten Sitzung da. Und ich hatte da gesagt, man sollte auf keinen Fall irgendwelche Zahlen nennen, weil man sich leicht vertun kann. Ich hatte das Beispiel von Geiss gebracht, mit seinen 99 Prozent. Er hat ja irgendwie gesagt, dass 99 Prozent der Bevölkerung nicht überwacht wird. Norbert Geiss. Genau. Und wenn man drüber nachdenkt, ist das natürlich völlig...
Eine riesen Zahl.
Eine riesen Zahl. Da bleiben 800.000, die überwacht werden, übrig. Was natürlich viel zu viel ist, aus dem meinte er nicht... Er sagte, die Menschen in Deutschland, das sind nicht nur die Bürger, sondern auch viel mehr. Das heißt, wir sind bei einer Million oder mehr, die nicht überwacht werden, die überwacht werden. Und das war natürlich viel zu viel. Da hat das dann hinterher der Schäuble korrigiert, indem er von 99,9 Prozent gesprochen hat, was immer noch sehr viele Überwachungsfälle bringt. Aber immerhin, solche Zahlen sind immer schlecht, wenn man es nicht genau weiß. Also besser nicht sagen. Ja, einen Tag später war dann die Sache, wo er dann Millionen und Milliarden verwechselt hat, der Andreas Baum. Also dabei gewesen wäre es vielleicht nicht passiert. In der zweiten Sitzung war er dabei. Da habe ich jetzt von Metaphern gesprochen. Und dann auch als Aufgabe. Ich hatte dann immer so Übungen gemacht. Und dann gab es immer ein Thema. Und dann sollte auch jeder in seine Kurzrede zu diesem Thema eine Metapher einbauen. Und da kam das dann auch mit dem gläsernen Abgeordnetenhaus. Und wenige Tage später war dann Andreas Baum wieder im Fernsehen. Es ging um Transparenz und der Rede vom gläsernen Abgeordnetenhaus. Da habe ich dann gleich gemerkt, ah, es bringt was mit der Rhetorik-Schulung. Das kann man dann gleich umsetzen. Also wie gesagt, es gibt da Übungen. Wie gesagt, die anderen machen das auch. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass zum Beispiel die Partei der Linken das macht. Denn ich glaube, im Augenblick hat man vor allen Dingen bei den Linken gute Redner im Bundestag. Also Gregor Gysi, es lohnt sich eigentlich immer, den zu hören. Vielleicht nicht inhaltlich, weil man nicht unbedingt inhaltlich auf seiner Seite steht, aber wie er die Sachen vorträgt, das ist einfach sehr, sehr gut.
Ja, da hat er eine Menge Schmiss drin.
Und er macht auch viel, er bewegt sich, er dreht sich hier hin und dahin, spricht an den Richter und der Bundeskanzlerin und so. Das macht er sehr gut. Und er hat auch so vollen Körpereinsatz. Also über das Rednerpult, was er ja absenkt, der ist sehr, sehr klein. Das sieht man dann, wenn er zum Rednerpult geht, klingt sich das immer ab, ganz nach unten. Aber dann ist er aber auch sehr präsent da drinnen hinweg. Das ist also sehr, sehr eindrucksvoll. Also ich glaube, das ist wirklich einer im Moment, im Bundestag einer der besten Redner, die da sind.
Wer würde dir sonst noch einfallen?
Ja, von den jetzigen.
Ja, auch so Dagewesenen, keine Ahnung.
Na ja, in der Vergangenheit gibt es wirklich ganz gute Beispiele. Also sicherlich Brandt. Also ist schon ein guter Redner. Auch Franz Josef Strauß. Also wenn er nicht betrunken war. Aber selbst dann, also er hat wirklich, also das ist rhetorisch sehr gut. Immer. Und auch da kann man immer genau erkennen, dass es strukturiert aufgebaut ist und so. Und auch die Dinge, wo man denkt, das ist jetzt eine Entgleisung, weil er irgendwie schimpft. Das passt aber sehr gut rein. Das ist dann schon sehr gut überlegt.
Das hat man ja noch gar nicht. Das hatten wir jetzt in unseren Tipps so noch nicht drin. Ausfällig werden, laut werden.
Kann man machen.
Also ich hab's mit der Tonhöhe schon mal versucht, so ein bisschen reinzubringen. Also so dieses Laut-Leise-Wechsel, gehört das dazu?
Ja, das gehört auch dazu. Also in der Debatte über Gutenberg kann man da sehr schön sehen, weil das da einfach dazu passt, jetzt mal so ein bisschen aus der Haut zu fahren und Ruhe zu zeigen. Da sieht man die verschiedenen Herangehensweisen. Ich glaube, ganz gelungen, der Beitrag von Lauterbach, obwohl das problematisch ist, weil der so einen rheinischen Akzent hat. Der hat immer so einen Sing-Sang. Das ist gewöhnungsbedürftig. Aber sonst war das auch sehr, sehr geschickt. Auch der ganze Redenaufbau, da hat man auch so richtig wow hinterher gesagt.
Lauterbach?
Lauterbach, wie der mit Vornamen heißt. Das war jedenfalls ein Parlamentarier von der SPD. Der ist auch Professor und hat sich deshalb bemüßigt gefühlt, tätig zu werden bei Gutenberg. Und meiner Meinung nach wirklich sehr, sehr geschickt.
Der mit der Fliege?
Ja, mit der Fliege, genau.
Karl Lauterbach.
Also richtig brillant an der Stelle. Auch mit Empörung, aber empörunggeschickt eingesetzt. Das Einzige, wie gesagt, dieser rheinische Sing-Sang ist halt gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Wird denn so Dialekt und Mundart als...
Ja, wird sehr viel eingesetzt. Ich sag ja, wir haben ja seit den 80er Jahren diesen schleichenden Populismus. Und um sich eben anzubiedern, greifen Politiker gerne dazu, da so ein bisschen einen Akzent einzusetzen. Vielleicht auch nach dem Vorbild von Helmut Kohl, der ja auch mit Akzent gesprochen hat. Aber das machen viele Leute. Also man merkt auch, dass es bewusst eingesetzt wird. Also bei Schäuble habe ich ja sogar schon mal vorgeführt. Bei der Pressekonferenz, wie er dann eben auch so ein bisschen mal so was mit Akzent sagt, um dann eben so Geschmäckchen rüber zu bringen. Ja, naja, das ist glaube ich hier, das ist da sehr verbreitet. Und natürlich auf Landesebene sowieso. Also da ist man ja sozusagen unter sich. Und da wird das sehr eingesetzt. Also in Bayern ist das ganz üblich. Und da ist Minister, wenn sie reden, dann plötzlich...
Voll bayouarisch aus.
Bayouarische Fallen. Obwohl sie das eigentlich gar nicht sollten, weil sie vielleicht gar keine richtigen Bayern sind. Sondern sie kommen irgendwie aus Franken oder so. Also der Bildungsminister, der damalige Goppel, das hab ich selber erlebt, da war ich anwesend. Da kam immer so ein Schwenk in den bayerischen Akzenten, wo der Franke ist, das ist dann irgendwie seltsam. Irgendwie wird das da erwartet. Dieses Mirs an mir muss irgendwie umgesetzt werden.
Ja, das gehört da wahrscheinlich dazu, wie das Bier.
Ja, genau, das spielt da sicherlich auch eine Rolle. Also ich denke nicht nur da, sondern gerade auf Landesebene. Das ist ja gerade das in der federalen Struktur. Also vielleicht in Nordrhein-Westfalen, wo man sprachlich zu sehr gemischt ist. Nördlich von Nordrhein-Westfalen ist halt Niederdeutsch. Da spricht natürlich keiner Niederdeutsch, aber man spricht halt mit einem gewissen Akzent. Das kommt dann gut an. Man denkt an Helmut Schmidt, der hat auch gesagt, obwohl er es gar nicht musste. Das ist ja nicht so schwer stört zu sagen, wenn man es darauf anlegt. Aber es ist natürlich auch so ein Zeichen. Ich glaube, er hat es bewusst getan, um was auszudrücken.
Um einen Alleinstellungsmerkmal dazu zu bringen.
Im Grunde auch, um zu sagen, ich bin einer aus dem Volk, obwohl er sonst immer sehr abgehoben geredet hat. Ich denke, das ist nochmal ein Unterschied zwischen Brandt und Schmidt.
Guter Redner?
Ja, ich glaube schon. Vielleicht nicht ganz so wie Brandt, aber dennoch glaube ich ein guter Redner.
Ja, die rhetorischen Mittel haben wir jetzt so alle aufgeführt?
Ja, alle nicht. Das kann man ja nicht vollständig aufführen, weil das da unheimlich viel ist.
Gibt es noch mehr?
Ja, natürlich gerade was die Anordnung angeht. Da gibt es halt die Möglichkeit, dann auch irgendwas auseinanderzuziehen und reinzuschieben.
Aber ich frage euch mal anders. Ist dir schon mal ein Redner vorgekommen, der so wie kein anderer war? Also der einfach irgendwie ein Mittel gebracht hat, was sich so nicht ohne Weiteres hat übernehmen lassen, was so ein Alleinstellungsmerkmal war? Das kann man irgendwie gar nicht kopieren.
Tja, weiß ich nicht. Nee, das ist eigentlich... Im Grunde kann man immer alles kopieren. Nee, also Alleinstellungsmerkmal... Weiß nicht, vielleicht im negativen Sinne. Das gibt's natürlich schon. Aber im positiven Sinne...
Kann man sich alles abgucken, sagst du?
Kann man sich alles abgucken, ja. Also ich denke, das ist immer alles nachahmbar. Und es gab es eigentlich auch alles schon. Also es gibt eigentlich immer für alles Vorbilder. Man, das sind ja die Möglichkeiten, sind ja begrenzt. Also da jetzt sich irgendwie was völlig Neues auszudenken.
Okay, also jeder, der sozusagen nochmal eine Politkarriere anstrebt, also muss ja nicht nur die Politik sein, sondern ist auch überhaupt so ein Amt, wo Vorträge halten, reden, schwingen, gefragt ist, wenn man sich noch lange noch in den Wind stellt, vor das Meer, mit dem Kieselstein, den Vögeln predigt, dann kann man da auch reinkommen.
Ja, gut, das reicht vielleicht immer noch nicht. Ja, der Humor muss man auch haben. Aber es kommt einiges zusammen, das denke ich schon.
Gut. Bruno ist ja schon beklagt, dass so ein Wesenzug heutzutage nicht mehr so populär ist, weil es auch nicht mehr so erforderlich ist, nämlich so, wie du sagtest, das Mimorieren der Rede, also sich das quasi auswendig lernen, was man so salopp formulieren darf. Warum ist das so wichtig?
Na ja, eben um sich vom Manuskript zu lösen. Dafür ist es halt wichtig und um auch das Publikum anzuschauen. Denn wenn man halt am Manuskript hängt, guckt man das Publikum nicht an.
Also du meinst jetzt gar nicht so sehr den Wortlaut, sondern eigentlich mehr so die Argumentationskette, sich zu merken, dass man eben nicht vom Manuskript abhängig ist, aber dass man dann einfach frei redet.
Genau, dass man frei redet, das ist sehr wichtig. Ja, beim Mimorieren gibt es halt zwei Aspekte. Einmal, dass man die Sachen weiß, die man sagen will. Das ist halt das Leichtere. Das wusste man auch schon in der antiken Rhetorik. Da gibt es Unterschiede zwischen Memorierungen auf der Ebene der Dinge, Res, und auf der Ebene der wirklichen Worte, Verber. Also Res und Verber können memoriert werden. Da wird in der Regel empfohlen, dass man natürlich die Sachen kennen muss. Also die Res. Das ist aber auch manchmal nützlich, sich an bestimmten Stellen auch Formulierungen vorher auszudenken, die man dann bringt.
Vor allem, damit man nicht in so eine besonders, was ich sehr häufig festgestellt habe in letzter Zeit, vielleicht ist das auch wieder so eine Wahrnehmung, dass das in letzter Zeit ist, dass so Sprichwörter benutzt werden oder so Redewendungen, aber dann irgendwie zwei unterschiedliche Redewendungen so miteinander verknüpft werden und dabei irgendwie gar nichts mehr Richtiges rauskommt. Vielleicht jetzt gerade kein gutes Beispiel.
Redewendungen sind halt immer auch...
Und der Oberknaller war ja jetzt gerade dieser Rick Perry im Vorwahlkampf der Republikaner. Hast du sicherlich auch gesehen, ne?
Nee, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Na, die haben doch dann immer diese Rededuelle, wo dann alle Kandidaten da, die sich im Fernsehen präsentieren. Und er hupt dann irgendwie an. Was er denn so ändern würde, war glaube ich die Frage, wenn er denn in der Regierung ist, dann meint er, er würde vor allem erst mal so drei Regierungsämter, also drei Ministerien, würde er ja abschaffen.
Stimmt, das habe ich gesehen noch.
Ja, und zwar, ich kriege sie jetzt gerade alle nicht zusammen, irgendwie das Erste und das Zweite, so. Und dann noch das, und das schlimm dann einfach nicht ein. Also es war, da fehlte der Res.
Genau, genau. Also das muss auf jeden Fall da sein, das dann einfällt, richtig.
Und wahrscheinlich hat er genau dann wiederum deinen Appell jetzt quasi nicht beherzigt, ja, also das Memorieren. Aber es ist ja vielleicht auch gar nicht so einfach. Ich meine, wie machst du das?
Ja, da gibt es halt noch Tricks, die gibt es auch schon seit der Antike. Naja, also ein Trick, das ist das Schema, also das Loki-Schema, sagt man, also Lucas der Ort, also das Schema nach Orten, dass man halt im Raum gewisse Teile des Raums in Verbindung zu bringen mit Inhalten, die man sagen will. Dann braucht man da nur hinzugucken und dann weiß man, ah, das wollte ich sagen. Und dann kann man sich auch so einen Weg durch den Raum bahnen, hat dann den Vorteil, dass man auch guckt, rumguckt, und dann von der einen Seite zur anderen Seite durch den Raum blicken und dann ist man immer erinnert an der Säule, da wollte ich das sagen, hinten wollte ich das sagen, da ist der Ausgang zum Garten, da will ich noch was anderes sagen und so. Also ich hab das zum Beispiel gemacht beim Ende des Programmbeitrags der Piraten im letzten Jahr, also der Landesmitteler Versammlung in Berlin, im letzten Jahr, wo das Programm beschlossen wurde, da hab ich zum Schluss auch noch so eine Zusammenfassung gemacht, wo man ja auch allen Leuten danken sollte. Und das ist natürlich immer schwierig, weil da niemand vergessen werden darf. Und dann hab ich mir das eben auch gemerkt anhand von Positionen im Raum. Dann bin ich durch den Raum geschritten in Gedanken und hab dann auch niemanden vergessen. Das lässt sich dann sehr schön...
Also in dem Fall die Position dieser Gruppen im Raum...
Ja, also man weiß, die Technik, die waren oben auf der Empore. Und dann muss man halt einmal beim Rungucken, sieht man halt die Empore und vergisst die dann nicht. Aber man sagt, ich geh von rechts unten nach oben, also im Dreieck und dann wieder runter. Und dann kann man sehen, also oben ist dann...
Ah, du hast quasi als geometrische Figur gelernt.
Genau, genau. Oben ist dann die Technik, links war der Ausgang zum Garten, da hatten die Leute gekocht. Das heißt, da hat man die Kochgruppe, rechts hat man die Bar. Hinter mir war die Versammlungsleitung mit Protokollanten. Und so konnte man also allen danken und ich hab keinen vergessen. Und da hat auch dann, also einer zumindest war ganz beeindruckt, dass ich aus dem Gedächtnis sowas mache, ohne jemanden zu vergessen. Denn da laufen die Leute immer beim Danken, immer mit einer Zettel rum.
Oh ja, das kenn ich gut. Ich kenn das, ich hab das ja beim Kongress lange Zeit in der Abschlussveranstaltung gemacht. Das war immer ganz furchtbar, weil man jemanden vergessen hat.
Das Schlimmste. Und man kann eben auch dann, sagen wir mal, wenn es um Programmpunkte geht, kann man das auch so machen, dass man denkt, also bestimmte Programmpunkte muss ich immer nennen und die muss man dann irgendwas festmachen. Also im Wahlkampf zum Beispiel. Jetzt ist man ja im Wahlkampf immer woanders. Das heißt, man hat nicht diese Orte, an denen man das festmachen kann. Aber man hat natürlich seinen Körper. Und da kann man natürlich an einzelnen Körperteilen gewisse Punkte festmachen, die man dann bringen kann. Da muss man nur da hingucken, wo man gerade ist. Hand zum Beispiel, die Hand hat was mit, wenn man sich jetzt verschiedene Dinge ausdenkt, mit Arbeiten zu tun. Dann nehme ich dann eben mindestens nur ein Grundeinkommen und denke an meine Hand und die Füße, die in der Fortbewegung. Das kann man, wenn man es nicht mit den Füßen tut, auch mit dem EPNV machen. Da hat man dann den fahrscheinlosen EPNV und denkt daran. Ja und so und so weiter. Auf diese Weise kann man eben gewisse Programmpunkte im Kopf behalten und wenn man dann in der Diskussion ist, dann fallen die einem auch ein. Und das ist ja wichtig, dass man im richtigen Punkt eben nicht wie Perry da steht und nicht mehr weiß. Der hätte sich einfach seine drei Ministerien auch so merken können. Da hätte er an jedem Punkt immer gewusst, Kopf, Bildung, so hatte ich das, Bildungspolitik, Kopf, Bildung, was so.
Wahrscheinlich wollte er auch nur deshalb drei Ministerien killen, weil es drei waren. Und noch nicht mal das hat funktioniert. Das ist natürlich sehr interessant. Ich meine, ich stelle das auch immer wieder bei Podcasts fest, wenn ich selber welche höre, höre das auch häufiger von Hörern, dass man, wenn man was hört und man bewegt, also vor allem, wenn man sich bewegt, man ist dann irgendwo, dass man später noch über Monate und Jahre vielleicht sich erinnern kann, was man gehört hat und das dann, also funktioniert über jede Richtung, dass man sowohl, wenn man sich daran erinnert, was man gehört hat, dass man dann weiß, wo man es gehört hat, als auch, wenn man an den Ort kommt, dann wiederum erinnert wird, was man da mal gehört hat. Oder auch überhaupt nur besser erinnern kann, weil man eben einen Ort hat für das, was man gehört hat und dass das auf einmal eine ganz andere Verfestigung hat. Offensichtlich scheint ja so Verortung und Sehen mit dem Hören an der Stelle wunderbar zusammenzugehen.
Ja, klar. Das sagen ja auch Schauspieler, dass wenn man auf der Bühne sich bewegt, an bestimmten Stellen, dass man dann den Text auch da leichter hat, als wenn man irgendwo statisch steht und was sagen muss.
Und die haben es ja eigentlich am schwersten, weil die müssen nur wirklich jedes Wort, jede Pause, jede Betonung sich merken. Und das sind dann so Techniken.
Ja, genau. Ich denke, so Techniken braucht man. Und es ist auch gut, dass man das macht. Also man kann sich nicht immer darauf verlassen, dass man irgendwo ablesen kann. Gerade im Wahlkampf geht das halt nicht.
Fragt sich, welchen Zeitaufwand man da reinstecken sollte.
Naja, so viel Zeitaufwand ist das nicht. Mir zu überlegen, wo ich die Themen festmache, Bildung am Kopf, Arbeit an der Hand.
Ja gut, memorieren. Aber wenn ich jetzt einen langen Vortrag habe, wo ich wirklich eine Stunde referiere über mehrere komplexe Sachen.
Ja, Mischformen sind da natürlich gut. Wenn du einen Vortrag hältst mit Slides, hast du deine Slides-Gedächtnisstütze. Das ist schon mal ganz gut. Und ohne Slides geht das ja auch. Heute hat man ja Podien mit entsprechenden Möglichkeiten, einen Zettel abzulegen. Dann hat man halt die wichtigsten Punkte auf dem Zettel. Dann kann man da zur Not hinschauen. Und so vergisst man dann nichts.
Ja, stimmt.
Und wenn man den Zettel nicht hat, muss man sich etwas anderes überlegen. Aber das ist dann aufwendiger. Dann muss man halt entweder mit diesem Lokalschema das machen oder mit irgendwelchen Bildern, die man sich vorstellt. Also bildliche Dinge sich vorzustellen, ist einfacher als sich irgendwelche abstrakten Sachen zu merken. Also man kann sich ja auch diesen Raum, den man durchschreitet, vorstellen.
Das ist ja dann wieder die Metapher in diesem Fall, aber um sich was zu merken. Gar nicht so sehr, um sie als Beispiel zu benutzen.
Ja, also ich halte das auf jeden Fall für wichtig, dass man sich Sachen vorher angeschaut hat und in gewisser Weise memoriert hat. Dann geht das Reden auch leichter, als wenn man ganz labisch an einem Manuskript hängt. Am schlimmsten ist das ja, wenn das Manuskript jemand anders geschrieben hat. Was kommt ja vor? Also gerade so Politiker auf der B- und C-Schiene, die dann eine geschriebene Rede, von jemand anderes geschriebene Rede ablesen, fürre ich da nicht.
Ja, im Fernsehen ist es ja super krass mit diesen Telepromptern. Ich glaube, Obama, wo wir jetzt vorhin diese Rede auch in Berlin genannt haben. Das sieht ja immer so aus, als ob er da frei redet. Tatsächlich haben sie diese Glas-Spiegel-Teleprompter, die so aus der Ferne überhaupt nicht auffallen. Das ist nur so ein dünner Stab zu sehen, wo dann halt irgendwie so eine Glasfläche dran ist und dann wird das irgendwie von unten da draufprojiziert. Ich meine, in dem Fall ist natürlich die Rede wirklich auch wirklich bis auf den letzten Takt geplant. Die läuft ja quasi in Echtzeit auf diesem Prompt ab. Man gibt das dann noch wieder und muss natürlich dann den richtigen Tonfall finden.
Ja gut, also dann ist es natürlich auch noch, also ich weiß nicht, bei dieser Wahlkampfrede ist es vielleicht noch nicht ganz so schlimm, obwohl das inzwischen natürlich auch schon gestiegene Anforderungen sind. Aber wenn dann ein Präsident im Amt ist, dann sollte natürlich kein Wort mit dem Zufall überlassen bleiben, weil das dann natürlich unter Umständen gleichdiplomatische Verwirrungen gibt. Deshalb muss er genau wissen, was er sagt. Da ist das natürlich wichtig mit dem Teleprompter.
Na gut, in dem Fall war er noch kein Präsident, aber stimmt schon, ein falsches Wort und wie Raketen fliegen. Ja, fünf Bereiche hast du ja angekündigt. Es waren jetzt aber bisher nur vier. Oder sind wir in den fünften schon irgendwie reinge...
Das war der Anfang, das war der Vortrag. Dann kam der Demosthenis.
Okay, also da geht es jetzt quasi um die Lautstärke etc. Ja genau, das ist das letzte, was man beherzigen muss.
Genau, ja nicht das letzte, die sind natürlich alle gleich wichtig, aber darüber muss man sich eben auch Gedanken machen. Über den Vortrag, also wie es gut klingt und so. Also wir hatten das ja schon. Mit den Tipps des Demosthenis, vielleicht kann man nochmal das anders zusammenfassen. Also es gibt da so allgemein den Tipp, man soll immer ruhig sprechen, also ruhig, nicht gehetzt und so, ruhig sprechen. Das ist auch schwierig. Viele Leute, auch gerade bei Vorträgen, gerade so auf dem Kongress hat man das oft, dass die so durchhetzen, durch ihre Folien. Irgendwie so getrieben von einem Zeitdruck, der gar nicht so schlimm ist. Also es ist besser, da ganz ruhig zu bleiben. Das wirkt auch besser. Eigentlich in jeder Situation. Gehetztes Reden ist immer schlecht. Also immer ruhig reden. Atmen, das vergessen leider auch viele. Das ist dann schrecklich. Dann kommt es auch zu diesen furchtbaren Schachtel-Sätzen und unmöglichen Pausen, weil man halt vergisst zu atmen. Also Atmen ist überhaupt das Wichtigste.
Naja, grundsätzlich auch.
Ja, Atmen wird völlig überschätzt.
Das gilt auch für die Hörer übrigens.
Ja, das sind auch Atmen.
Auch wenn man da jetzt atemlos zuhören möchte, nicht übertreiben.
Ja, Lautstärke haben wir schon genannt. Also man soll natürlich laut sprechen. Das ist natürlich bei Mikrofonanlagen immer schwierig. Da muss man das richtig abstimmen.
Kann man das, also hab ich glaube ich vorhin schon mal gefragt, aber irgendwie, ich frag mich immer noch, wie erlernbar das ist, die Lautstärke zu steigern.
Ja, das ist erlernbar. Da gibt es ja Stimmbildung für Sänger und für Sprecher.
Ja gut, und da generiert man dann auch Lautstärke.
Ja klar.
Also ist dann die Körperhaltung entscheidend?
Ja, Körperhaltung, man muss halt mehr sein, also Druck aus dem Zwergfeld, aus dem Zwergfeld. Das Zwergfeld ist halt wichtig, wenn man von da aus drückt und nicht von hier oben aus dem Kielkopf. Das wird natürlich nicht laut. Und normalerweise ist genug Resonanzvolumen da. Sein Körper ist schon groß genug.
Jeder kann laut reden.
Ja.
Wenn er will.
Und wenn er sich Mühe gibt sozusagen.
Also muss man üben, natürlich. Also manchen ist es natürlich so gegeben, laut zu sprechen. Aber andere müssen das dann nochmal lernen.
Ja, ich merke das immer ganz stark bei so Hörer-Treffen, wo es dann auch nicht selten immer so ein bisschen lauter drumherum ist, weil man sich so in Gaststätten trifft. Natürlich ist das ja quasi wie das Meer und der Wind. Da haben wir ihn. War jetzt letztens grad auch ein bisschen schwieriger. Da merkt man halt sehr, wie schwer sich manche tun, diese Lautstärke zu erzeugen. Ich meine, teilweise mag es vielleicht gar nicht so sehr dieses Nicht-Können sein, als eben auch so Nicht-Wollen. Also dieses sich nicht selbst hören können oder nicht frei reden. Das ist ja auch, denke ich mal, weiß nicht, ob das jetzt überhaupt noch in das Feld der Rhetorik reinpasst, aber allein dieses Reden können, also dieses nicht befangen sein, dieses nicht komplett auch mental so psychisch zusammenzuklappen, wenn man auf einmal so von einer großen Masse von Menschen steht. Was, also ich weiß nicht, beschäftigt sich jetzt so die klassische Rhetorik auch mit solchen Sachen oder ist das einfach nochmal ein anderes Feld?
Ja, also sicher, das wird auch irgendwo behandelt.
Man muss ja auch sicher wirken, wenn man da so fahrig verloren, nicht nur gehetzt, sondern eben auch so ein bisschen, es schafft ja Unsicherheit, Unsicherheit bringt einen dann natürlich auf jeden Fall auch aus dem Tritt. Wirkt vielleicht auch unglaubwürdig, weil man auf einmal das Gefühl hat, warum zittert der da so in der Stimme, warum kann sie ja jetzt diesen Punkt so nicht rüberbringen, wo gehen die Blicke hin?
Ja, das steht auch noch auf meiner Liste, haben wir noch nicht, Blickkontakt. Das ist halt ganz wichtig. Man muss immer mit dem Publikum Blickkontakt halten. Also immer mit dem, dem man anspricht Blickkontakt halten. Also schon gar nicht aus meinem Script gucken. Oder ganz schlimm, sich umzudrehen, auf die Slides zu gucken.
Und dann vorlesen.
Und dann vorlesen noch. Wollte ich auch wirklich.
So sollte man eigentlich auch immer so eine Tüte Tomaten dabei haben.
Ja, das ist wirklich unglaublich. Es gibt ja auch auf dem Kongress da dieses Hacker-Japany. Und dann auch der Präsentator ständig auf die... Also er hat immer den Rücken zum Publikum. Wenn er zwar ein Headset hat, sodass er trotzdem verstanden wird. Also ich hab den immer nur von hinten gesehen. Das finde ich da schon irgendwie unangenehm.
Na was kann man da... Also beherzigen. Gut, also Blickkontakt. Klar, aber jetzt nochmal so spezifisch auf diese Angst-Überwindung. Wie rampensauig bist du da, als dass das für dich jetzt dein Problem ist? Oder hast du auch mal irgendwas überwinden müssen?
Das ist schon ein Problem. Da muss man schon vor 1500 Leuten zu sprechen auf dem Kongress. Da ist man nervös, ganz klar. Und deshalb ist es auch gut am Anfang das Eis zu brechen.
Auch für sich selbst.
Für sich selbst. Diese Kapazio benevolentia ist auch etwas, was man für sich selbst braucht. Wenn man am Anfang schon mal ein Lacher hat, dann ist das gut. Dann fühlt man sich wohler. Ist übrigens auch, wenn du mal guckst, wenn du mal vergleichst Vortragende aus den USA, da ist das irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob die das in der Schule lernen, aber da ist das sehr, sehr häufig, dass am Anfang ein Witz kommt.
Ja, also wie weit sie das spezifisch jetzt in der Schule werden, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich hab gehört, ich hab da keine konkreten Erfahrungen, aber dass so dieses, überhaupt das freie Vortragen einfach da in der Schule einen größeren Stellenwert hat. Vielleicht ist das hier auch noch ein Problem, so ein Untern. Man ist ja nicht so, dass man nie einen Vortrag hält, aber irgendwie scheint es immer so ein bisschen die Ausnahme zu sein. Dass man so, oh Gott, jetzt muss ich mal vor der ganzen Klasse stehen und was vortragen. Normalerweise ist die Bringschuld immer dadurch erfüllt, dass man so die Hausarbeiten vorne diskret auf den Tisch legt und dann wird im stillen Kämmerlein da so ein bisschen rumkritisiert und dann ist das Ergebnis fertig. Würde man aber quasi alles, man schlägt jetzt auch vom Zeitmanagement her in der Klasse nichts machen, aber würde man eben mehr auch immer selber präsentieren, würde sich das wahrscheinlich auch ganz anders einschlafen. Ich weiß nicht, ich hab das immer ein bisschen genossen, ich weiß gar nicht warum, aber auch diese Nervosität, die da ist. Also ich glaube, dass das auch sehr erfahrene Sprecher eigentlich auch immer, das stelle ich mal, dass einer also komplett frei davon ist, glaube ich nicht. Die Frage ist nur, wie man diese Energie umwandelt. Man kann das ja auch als Antrieb nutzen. Mir hilft es zum Beispiel enorm, mich dann auch zu konzentrieren, weil ich ja auch mal merke, da ist so ein Druck, die Hände werden auch so ein bisschen feucht, also der Körper signalisiert einem, okay, jetzt geht es los. Nur sollte man eben nicht den Fehler machen, daran zu zerbrechen, sondern es einfach, dass du ein bisschen meine Mädchen rechnen und dich da aufmachst, ich versuche das einfach so einzusammeln und so als Antrieb zu sehen, dass man sich dann konzentriert, dass man auch wirklich, dann macht man glaube ich auch viele dieser anderen Fehler nicht mehr. Dann denkt man die ganze Zeit darüber nach oder hat im Hinterkopf immer so, ok, worauf will ich jetzt im nächsten Slide hinaus? Also auch so dieser Wechsel, dieser Pace, den man dann hat, dieses wie bereite ich das vor? Wo einem ja auch so kleine Tricks helfen können, sodass man seinen Slide gar nicht so sehr unternehmt. Also einerseits sollen sie einem ja auch helfen. Sie helfen einem ja vielseitig. Zum Beispiel können sie einem ja auch helfen, diesen Witz drüber zu bringen. Dass man irgendwas vorbereitet, sodass man da so ein bisschen eine Erwartungshaltung reinlegt und dann bricht man das irgendwie auf, indem man halt mit irgendeinem Joke hinterherkommt oder sich dann alle einfach nur noch wegwerfen. Aber wenn man dann eben diesen letzten Schritt dann auch nicht memoriert, das ist an der Stelle sehr wichtig, wie man jetzt diese Überleitung macht, kann man sich natürlich diesen ganzen Witz dann auch wieder komplett ruinieren. Oder auch einfach den normalen Flow eben so ruinieren.
Ja, da gibt es ja schöne Beispiele. Ich erinnere mich da noch, das ist auch im Gedächtnis, sowas bleibt dann im Gedächtnis. Damals hast du auf dem Kongress, bei der Kongresseröffnung diese Sache mit der Telefonnummer gebracht hast aus dem, was ist das noch? Großartig, also wow.
Die Rufnummer, wo man sich hinwenden kann.
Meine Güte, also wirklich ein großer Teil des Publikums, auch ich, haben sich ja weggeworfen vor Lachen. Und immer wieder schön. Und dann dieses lange... Das ist eisgebrochen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Nummer war, aber sie war lang.
Naja, da war das eisgebrochen. Das war natürlich ein guter Scherz, denn selbst die, die es nicht kannten, haben gleich gesagt...
Also man muss das noch nicht mal kennen, und es war trotzdem lustig.
Ja, so geht das dann. Es war eigentlich ein billiges Mittel, aber man hat die Leute für sich vereint. Und alle hören zu.
Genau, und dann ist es halt auch für beide Seiten einfacher. Das merkt man dann auch. Klar, wenn der natürlich nach hinten losgegangen wäre, der Witz, was nicht zu erwarten war, hätte man damit auch erst mal wieder klarkommen müssen. Aber es ist ja eigentlich auch relativ einfach. Und das ist eigentlich auch etwas, was, glaube ich, was man sich als Redner auch klar machen will, das Publikum hat ja eigentlich ein großes Interesse daran, mit diesem Vortragen dann auch irgendwie so ein Bonding einzugehen. Man betreibt ja da auch ein Spiel, aber ich denke, es gibt da sehr viel Wohlwollen und man muss eigentlich nur an der richtigen Stelle andocken. Wenn man dann einfach so viele bewusste Fehler macht, mit nicht hingucken, lalala, ja, weiß ich nicht, auch nicht dabei sein, unkonzentriert sein oder eben dieses furchtbare Vorlesen, dann verspielt man eigentlich so den Bonus, den man eigentlich immer hat, den man eigentlich immer hat. Leute klatschen, wenn man da irgendwie hinkommt. Man hat ja noch gar nichts gemacht. Man ist einfach nur da. Trotzdem gibt es schon so diese Appreciation, diesen Vorschuss, den man einfach einsammeln kann und dann einfach auch, man tankt ja die Leute dann quasi schon im Vorfeld auf, so ja, hier, jetzt kriegst du auch so Energie und jetzt mach mal. Jetzt wollen wir aber auch bespaßt werden.
Das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall eine Interaktion. Deshalb ist es auch wichtig, dass man hinguckt, denn die gucken ja auch zurück.
Ja, auch wenn es natürlich so viele sind, da weiß man nicht so richtig, wo man hingucken soll. Manche schießen sich auf so ein Feld ein, das ist dann auch manchmal ein bisschen blöd, dass man immer so dieselbe Gruppe nimmt, wo man dann irgendwann nur noch das Gefühl hat, die redet jetzt irgendwie nur mit diesem Teil und mit dem nicht. Komischerweise, glaube ich, braucht man das manchmal auch, dass man sich zumindest so ein bisschen einschränkt und nicht die ganze Zeit nur Kopf links und nach rechts, oben und unten, und versucht irgendwie so alles immer mit dem Laserstrahl zu tuschieren.
Das funktioniert natürlich auch nicht. Es gibt natürlich auch so Beispiele, dass jemand dann ständig auf und ab geht auf der Bühne, das ist auch nicht gut.
Ja, da gibt es so richtige Renner. Fühlt sich nicht gut.
Ein bisschen Bewegung schon, aber wenn jemand ständig auf und ab geht, dann immer so das Bild eines gefangenen Tigers, der im Käfig da hin und her läuft. Der Panther. Genau das. Das ist unangenehm, finde ich. Also schon gut, wenn der nicht immer da statisch ist, sondern sich auch mal ein bisschen bewegt, aber ein bisschen halt, nicht so übertrieben. Und nicht in so einem richtig festen Rhythmus immer hin und zurück. Das war heute was von Pong. Ja, ich meine, das ist schon wichtig. Es gibt noch viele andere Dinge, die aber auch schwierig sind. Die richtige Stimmlage bewusst zu finden, ist schwierig.
Was ist denn die richtige Stimmlage?
Das hängt natürlich auch vom Thema ab, was man sagt. Bei Ironie ist vielleicht ein bisschen eine andere Stimmlage nötig, als wenn man irgendwelche ernsten Sachen sagt und so. Das ist ganz, ganz schwierig, weil man das schon so schwer beschreiben kann.
An der Stelle habe ich gemerkt, auch bei Workshops zum Beispiel, wo man ja noch sehr viel mehr redet, wenn man den ganzen Tag dabei ist, die Leute zu erhalten, dass es mir sehr viel gebracht hat, immer vorher sich ein Bild von den Leuten zu machen. Beim Vortrag ist das nur in Ausnahmefällen möglich. Man kann vielleicht mal so über ein oder zwei Sachen so ein Stimmungsbild reinholen, jetzt bei Kongresseröffnungen oder so weiter. Da gehört das vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen dazu. Aber bei Workshops ist es natürlich eine ganz andere Geschichte. Ich meine, da ist die Rhetorik noch viel wichtiger, weil man ja wirklich auch aktiv lehrt. Also man will ja da wirklich Wissen vermitteln und man muss das rüberbringen. Und häufig oder leicht kann man den Fehler machen, dass man einfach an den Leuten vorbei redet, schlicht und ergreifend, weil man ihnen nicht erzählt, was für sie relevant ist. Und wenn man einfach vorher fragt, weiß ja was ich, also auch eine Vorstellungsrunde kann immer schon sehr viel ändern. Dass man einfach schon mal Namen, Koordinaten, irgendwie Herkunft, keine Ahnung, aber eben auch ganz wichtig, Erwartungshaltung abklären. Das ist eigentlich immer das, was ich hier als erstes mache. Also was ist deine Voraussetzung? Was ist deine Erwartungshaltung? Worauf freust du dich? Was fehlt dir? Wo ist die eigentliche Wissenslücke, die gestumpft werden soll? Oder gibt es vielleicht auch in dem Sinne keine? Und es geht nur mehr um so eine Praxis, dass man einfach ausloten kann, wo es gewichtig war. Weil wenn man dann natürlich einen Vortrag, der jetzt für irgendeine beliebige Gruppe mal gemacht wurde, hält und man gar nicht ins Schwarze trifft, einfach die ganze Zeit irgendwas erzählt, was überhaupt nicht interessiert, dann kann man natürlich noch so gut reden. Da sitzen alle so und denken sich so, ja wann geht es denn los? Ich hatte irgendwann mal die Situation, dass ich so einen einwöchigen Workshop gefahren bin, wo es um bestimmte Computersysteme ging. Also in dem Fall irgendwie so um Unix. Und da gab es halt damals im Wesentlichen so zwei Flavors. Es gab halt irgendwie das System 5 und diese BSD-Ecke. Normalerweise war das halt immer alles System 5, die ganzen Folien, alle Details waren auf das eine vorbereitet. Und es fanden sich halt einfach nur die anderen Systeme da. Was habe ich da gerudert, um einfach das dann auszugleichen? Aber ich wusste zumindest, was das Problem war und habe das dann irgendwie so versucht, aktiv zu begleiten. Und ich glaube, nochmal extra viel Humor auch versucht da irgendwie reinzulegen. Und war danach ganz schockiert fast, dass die Bewertung des Kurses gut ausfiel, wo ich mir dachte, das kann ja eigentlich gar nicht sein. Also alles, was vorbereitet war, passt nicht. Bei jedem Detail muss ich sagen, naja, eigentlich ist es so, aber ihr müsst hier noch eine andere Kommando-Zahlenoption. Und die Kommando heißt anders, und die Datei ist auch woanders. Und so und alles ist anders. Aber trotzdem kann man darüber dann auch eine ganze Menge retten, wenn die Leute merken, dass man sich dann eben auch bemüht.
Ja, da kann man viel machen. Ich hab ja mehrfach auch Vorträge über Liquid Feedback und hatte nicht meine eigenen Folien dafür.
Was ja auch schon mal Thema war, hinten.
Ja, weil das mit den Screenshots etwas schwierig ist. Man will ja illustrative Screenshots haben, aber wenn man aus dem Originalsystem Screenshots macht, muss man ja Sachen anonymisieren oder muss die Leute vorher fragen und so. Deshalb hatte Andreas Nietzsche, der ja da auch Entwickler ist, Screenshots und Folien vorbereitet. Und ich hab die dann genommen, um meinen Vortrag zu halten. Und das in unterschiedlichen Kreisen. Also es gab dann einfach nur Leute, also auf der SICK-Info, wo man mal sagt, was ist das eigentlich? Kannte noch keiner, erzählt man dann. Oder eben bei den Datenspuren in Dresden, wo dann alles Leute saßen, die das schon kannten und jetzt eben vielleicht was Kritisches hören wollten, mit den gleichen Folien. Da muss man sich schon auf das Publikum einstellen, sonst geht das komplett schief. Also wenn ich jetzt den SICK-Info-Vortrag genauso an den Datenspuren gehalten hätte, wär das... Jaja, nach hinten losgegangen. So hab ich das dann angepasst, aber mit denselben Folien. Was natürlich noch mal eine zusätzliche Schwierigkeit ist. Wow, wenn man dieselben Folien hat, aber was anderes dazu sagen muss. Aber da gibt's auch gute Übungen. Pecha-Kucha zum Beispiel.
Oh, das hab ich mal gemacht. Das war toll. Ich glaube, dass man das offiziell Pecha-Kucha ausspricht.
Ah ja, genau. Das U nennt man ja was recht. Das U ist ja so ein Neutralvokal im Japanischen. Okay, dann hab ich das richtig gehört.
Das hast du schon mal gemacht.
Nein, hab ich noch nicht gemacht. Ich war bisher nur Zuschauer, aber mehrmals.
Das muss man vielleicht mal kurz erläutern. Man macht einen Vortrag, in dem man 20 Bilder zeigt, die jeweils 20 Sekunden lang angezeigt werden. Man ist halt in einem festen Zeitakt. Das heißt, man ist komplett durchformatiert. Man gibt vorher seine Slides ab. Es müssen nicht Bilder sein, aber das ist so ein bisschen die Tradition, dass man es vor allem mit Fotos macht, es gibt auch Ausnahmen. Und das habe ich einmal gemacht. War ein dankbares Thema für mich. Es ging halt um Blink-Lights, wo ich inhaltlich aus dem Vollen schöpfen konnte, weil ich natürlich alles wusste darüber. Und natürlich auch das Bildmaterial gepasst hat. Trotz alledem war die Herausforderung einfach enorm. Weil ich musste mir sehr genau Gedanken darüber machen, wie lange rede ich über irgendwas. Passt das, dass ich den Punkt des Bildes dann auch wirklich in 21 Sekunden reinbringe? Und dann natürlich auch immer diesen Spannungsbogen, über den wir vorhin schon mal geredet haben, mit einbauen kann, dass man einfach auf das nächste Bild, dass das nächste Bild einfach immer wieder eine Überraschung ist oder immer noch mal eine Steigerung ist. Oder, keine Ahnung, dass es einfach immer wieder irgendwas rüberbringt. Dass man etwas ankündigt, gibt es schon so eine Erwartungshaltung, und dann alle ganz gespannt, und dann bäng, und dann kommt es rein, und dann ist es nochmal lustiger. Was weiß ich zum Beispiel, dieses Bild aus dem ersten Blinklite, wo diese ganze Steuerverkabelung dann quasi auf diesen Tisch draufgelötet wurde, und dann war kein Platz, und dann ging das irgendwie noch am Tisch, an der Seite, so runter und gehörte ja auch noch irgendwie dazu. Wenn man das so sieht, mit nichts kann man besser hacken, erklären als damit, aber es ist trotzdem einfach immer wieder so ein sicherer Lacher. Aber da wurde einem klar, wie wichtig eben dieses Timing auch ist.
Das ist wirklich eine sehr, sehr gute Übung. Also ich kann das eigentlich nur empfehlen.
Ja, das ist auch wirklich, glaube ich, was man so, vielleicht ist das auch ein guter Rat, dass man vielleicht mal so im privaten Umfeld, also keine Ahnung, so hier, ich und meine Freunde im Keller, dass man sich einfach mal so einen kleinen Pitchakta-Abend macht, und dann, keine Ahnung, jeder stellt ein Internetmem vor. Ja, so mit dieser Methode. Kann man ja dann noch variieren, schneller, langsamer, mehr Bilder, weniger Bilder oder so. Muss man halt irgendwie sein Ding finden. Aber ich glaube, das ist ganz gut, um diesen Vortragsflow auch erst mal so sich zu erarbeiten.
Ja, eine andere gute Übung ist natürlich, sich selbst aufzunehmen auf Video. Also das ist praktisch das Pendant zu dem Most in der Spiegel. Heute hat man ja Video. Und ich habe ja mal diese Übung gemacht da, bei der Berliner Piratenpartei, was ich vorhin schon erzählt habe. Und das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Auch die Lerngeschwindigkeit dann. Also gerade jemand, der sich gerade selbst gesehen hat und auch gesehen hat, was er falsch macht, insbesondere auch mit der Gestik und so, dass die Hände so zusammenfalten, so ein bisschen so wie Angela Merkel. Das wirkt natürlich dann sehr verkrampft und so. Und direkt danach, bei der zweiten Übung, also ist der Lerneffekt enorm, weil all das dann plötzlich weggefallen ist. Also das ist unheimlich, wenn man sich das mal selber gesehen hat und merkt, es geht ja gar nicht, dass man sich dann wunderbar korrigieren kann.
Ja, das ist auch ein bisschen schlimm dann immer.
Ja, das ist gruppendynamisch sehr, sehr schwierig. Deshalb mag ich sagen ja ungern, weil halt die Leute in ihrem Ego stark berührt werden. Aber der Lerneffekt ist hoch.
Genau.
Also auch eine sehr gute Übung. Denn ich denke, reden lernen kann man nicht nach Buch. Das muss man wirklich durch Übung machen. Vielleicht ist das auch ganz gut in Deutschland, dass wir so ein Parteien-System haben, wo man erstmal den langen Marsch hat. Und nicht gleich oben anfängt. Das ist vielleicht auch nochmal der Unterschied. Obwohl man auch bei einigen Leuten, die einen langen Marsch hinter sich haben, sich fragt, wie haben sie das geschafft. Aber wahrscheinlich haben die da auch noch andere Sachen eingesetzt, andere Mittel, die dann auf die Füße fallen später.
Ja, aber aus Respekt vor dem Amt. Gehen wir jetzt nicht weiter in die Tiefe. Gibt es denn sonst noch etwas, wo wir noch weiter in die Tiefe gehen müssten? Oder ist jetzt alles gesagt?
Wir haben, glaube ich, das Wesentliche gesagt. Man kann natürlich alles vertiefen.
Man kann es auch endlos in die Länge ziehen. Das ist ja auch nicht gut für einen Vortrag.
Nee, ist auch nicht gut. Man muss da immer ein Ende finden. Das ist sehr, sehr richtig. Da gibt es auch Experten, die man das extra sagen muss. Also ich kenne Leute, die reden wunderbar. Aber nach drei Minuten fangen sie an, irgendwie Dinge in die Länge zu ziehen. Und dann ist es aus. Und dann kommt auch nicht mehr die Kurve. Sonst sind sie sozusagen über die Bande hinaus. Und dann ist Schluss. Dann kommt nichts Gutes mehr. Also man muss den Leuten wirklich sagen, hört auf. Also am besten so eine Drei-Minuten-Grenze oder so, wenn es Diskussionsbeitrag ist, weil es danach nicht mehr geht.
War das jetzt schon unser starkes Argument zum letzten Aufbäumen?
Oder war das schon der Tweet? Das Tweet wäre dann, fasse dich kurz. Heute wird da eher das Gegenteil stehen.
Ja, das stimmt. Fasse dich kurz. Da ist was dran. Aber bring es auf den Punkt.
Genau.
Das ist das Wichtige.
Diese Rede, die wir da gesehen haben, die kenne ich gerade, ist ja eben auch nur neun Minuten lang. Mit allem Applaus. Sehr kurz eigentlich, wenn die Geschichte eingegangen ist. Die von Ernst Leuter natürlich auch. Und die früheren sowieso, weil die Leute das alles schreien mussten. Da ging es ja nicht so lang. Das geht nicht so lang. Der Fidel Castro hat dann natürlich ein Mikrofon. Deshalb kann er 16 Stunden am Stück reden.
Ja, also, wer sich hier zum Redner oder Diktatoren bringen möchte, ich hoffe, da waren jetzt ein paar hilfreiche Anmerkungen dabei. Jetzt warten wir aber nicht wieder drei Jahre mit dem nächsten Thema, oder? Danke fürs Zuhören.